Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 477 vom, was haben wir denn heute? Dezember.
Erster Dezember, ganz neu, ein frischer neuer Dezember 2023.
Der dritte 20er Dezember, das wird, also vielleicht, das finde ich immer so,
das war so die dunkelsten Zeiten im Leben.
Die Dezember der 20er Jahre.
Also 2020, Dezember 2020, Briefpunkt, dann dachte man so boah jetzt ist es vorbei,
dann kamen 21, 22, 23, sogar der vierte schon.
Naja, ist ja alles ne Einstellungsfrage ne? Ich weiß, jetzt kommen die goldenen
20er, ich wollte, ich hab das, ich hab das. Die goldenen 20er kommen halt zum
Ende der 20er, das ist jetzt alles nur, das baut sich langsam auf.
Ich wollte das nur jetzt am Anfang der Sendung hinter mich bringen mit deinen
goldenen 20ern, damit ich mich nicht am Ende aufrege.
Verstehe. Okay, ich wollte ja gar nichts zu sagen. Ich wollte mich jetzt erstmal
bedanken bei Olaf für das schöne Intro.
Ja, das ist ein sehr nettes Grußwort vom Katz.
Ja, wir haben die besten Hörer. Ich sprich nochmal ein Intro ein.
Danke Olaf. Ja, genau. Heute mal ein bisschen anders als sonst,
weil wir mal dachten, wir machen mal wieder eine kleine Spezialsendung und fokussieren
uns mal ein bisschen und haben dazu auch einen Gast eingeladen,
nämlich den Stefan. Stefan Pelzer.
Hallo.
Moin.
Herzlich willkommen bei Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Danke. Ich bin hier schon so fast wie zu Hause angekommen ehrlich gesagt.
Ja?
Ja, es hat lange gedauert, bis die Aufnahme startete.
Es gibt vor dem eigentlichen Prolog noch so einen längeren Pro-Prolog, der zwar auf diesen,
Mikrofon landet, aber nicht in,
der Sendung. Aber den haben wir jetzt überwunden und,
sind quasi live, wenn auch nicht linear.
Ist halt nicht so einfach, den richtigen Witz auszusuchen.
Ich musste gerade überdenken, als ich euch bei Olaf bedankt hab,
kennt ihr noch, wenn so Radiosender sagen so, hey, hier ist Britney Spears and
you're listening to KDRN.
Hey, this is Olaf and you're listening to LNP.
Hallo, hier ist Olaf Scholz und ihr hört Lackbuch Netzpolitik.
WLNP!
Ja, das ist, wer weiß, vielleicht schickt er uns ja jetzt noch schnell ein Grußwort vom Kanzler.
Das ist ja auch immer live eingesprochen, die sind ja dann da im Studio.
Die sind da immer dann da, genau. Und ich glaube jetzt ist das auch soweit synthetisiert,
aber ich bin auf Mute natürlich.
Natürlich, möchtest du gerne freigeschaltet werden?
Ja gerne, sehr gerne.
Womit auch langsam klar ist, wovon die Rede ist. Oder was heute das Sendungsthema ist.
Aber vorher müssen wir noch Geschenke austauschen.
Ich hab nämlich, Stefan, für dich, du bist ja, also du weißt ja,
wir haben ja damals über...
Jetzt musst du ja erstmal erzählen, womit er affiliert ist.
Und damit möchte ich ihn ja gerade vorstellen. Ich schenke ihm ja nur was,
damit wir den Hörerinnen erklären können, wer er ist.
Verstehe.
Und zwar nennen sich unsere Hörerinnen ja die LNP Einhorn-Standarte.
Ja.
Und vielleicht kannst du ja erzählen, während ich dir jetzt hier diesen schönen
LNP Einhorn-Standarte-Aufkleber überreichere als Geschenk, woher dieser Name kam und wie das war.
Und zwar war es so, als wir, also ich bin, und da muss ich mich dann doch vorstellen,
ich bin ja vom Zentrum für politische Schönheit.
Und wir haben mal ein Mahnmal vor, eine Kopie des Holocaust-Mahnmals in den
Nachbargarten von Björn Höcke gesetzt.
Und damals rief jemand uns an und beschimpfte unter anderem mich und der sagt,
er ist von der AfD Totenkopfstandarte und du wirst erschossen.
Hörst du, du wirst erschossen.
Und genau. Und das haben wir glaube ich auch irgendwo abgespielt oder ich habe
das Audio weitergeleitet.
Und daraufhin habt ihr die Gegenbewegung zur AfD, Totenkopfstandarte,
gegründet, die ja sehr wütend ist und habt die nicht so sehr wütende.
LNP Einhorn Standarte gegründet.
Mit Hooligan Einhorn und Standarte und allem was dazu gehört.
Da machen wir guten Umsatz mit, mit der Werbung.
Machen wir? Ich hab noch nichts von gemerkt.
Nein, da gibt es vereinzelte Käuferinnen und Käufer, die dieses Motiv auf Shirts kaufen.
Ja, ist auch ein geiles Motiv.
Auf raumbildenden Packmitteln.
Und auf raumbildenden Packmitteln.
Was sind raumbildende Packmittel?
Das weißt du nicht? Das soll jeder Stammhörer von LNP wissen.
Raumbildende Packmittel ist eine technisch korrekte Beschreibung für das,
was du vielleicht einen Jutebeutel nennen würdest.
Aber der ist nicht aus Jute. Und das ist auch kein Beutel, weil...
Das ist Plastikgüter.
Ah shit, wir haben angefangen, Jutebeutel zu verkaufen.
Tim hat angefangen, ohne mich zu fragen, habe ich mich auch darüber geärgert.
Weil ich Jutebeutel schlecht finde.
Und dann mussten wir aber lange darüber, dann wurden wir berichtigt,
dass es keine Beutel sind und nicht aus Jute.
Und deswegen verkaufen wir, haben wir
dann mehrere Folgen damit verbracht herauszufinden, was es denn genau ist.
Und jetzt hat man gehört, was in meinem Raum binnen dünnen Packmittel ist.
Du bist vom Zentrum für politische Schönheit und du kollaborierst jetzt mit dem Kanzler.
Ja, also ich arbeite direkt für das Bundeskanzleramt sozusagen und in der Social
Media Abteilung, als Gmail.com.
Dazu kommen wir gleich aber noch. Ja, ich erzähle euch ein bisschen was zur
aktuellen ZBS Aktion, dem AfD Verbot und zur geilsten Rede, die Olaf Scholz nie gehalten hat.
Bevor du das machst sollten wir vielleicht noch die Leute mitnehmen,
die vielleicht nicht ganz so up to date sind, was euer Projekt betrifft.
Also wir hatten ja ZBF hier schon.
Öfters mal in dieser Sendung sozusagen.
Aber nicht persönlich?
Naja doch, wir hatten Cezi Leonard bei unserer Lennon P300 auf der Bühne,
also das war auch ganz toll.
Und wir haben uns natürlich auch mit vielen von euren Aktionen schon auseinander gesetzt.
Unter anderem halt Totenkopfstandarte, die Geschichte, das haben wir ja auf
jeden Fall ordentlich gefeiert.
Aber das ist ja beileibe nicht das einzige. Ich will das jetzt auch gar nicht
alles aufzählen, ich will nur sagen, das ist sozusagen so ein bisschen so ein…
Was war eure Lieblingsaktion?
Wir sind kultureller Begleiter. Lieblingsaktion?
Ja, jeder hat doch eine Lieblingsaktion.
Ich glaube… Oh man, das ist eine gute Frage, da müsste ich mich jetzt erstmal an alle erinnern.
Was war deine?
Also ja, ich fand immer, auf jeden Fall muss ich sagen, also Flyerservice,
also immer die aktuellen, das sind die Besten, aber Flyerservice Hahn war natürlich
was für die Herzen. Also das Mahnmal, also bei mir gibt es zweimal Platz 1.
Ne, es gibt natürlich einen Platz 1, das ist die aktuelle, so viel zur Formalität
und meinem vorgegebenen Wording.
Das sind alles Lieblings- Und wenn ihr mir ins Herz schaut, weil die aktuelle,
das kann man auch erst später begutachten, aber wenn ich retrospektiv schaue,
ist schon das Mahnmal beim Höcke und der Flyerservice Hahn sind die Sachen,
auf die man dann doch so ein bisschen stolzer ist als auf die anderen Sachen.
Steht das Mahnmal eigentlich noch?
Ja, ist sogar saniert, muss wahrscheinlich bald wieder saniert werden,
aber ich hab jetzt auch das mit dem
echten Mahnmal, das echte Mahnmal muss wahrscheinlich auch saniert werden.
Das heißt da könnte er bei der Baustelle einfach direkt ein bisschen was abgraben?
Nein und nein. Aber ja, wir haben es mal saniert und wir haben halt einen sehr
attraktiven Mietvertrag dort.
Beim Nachbarn von Höcke. Wir nehmen das ja auch immer für unsere Crowdfundings,
die gibt es dieses Mal nicht, aber sonst gab es immer den 1000 Euro Perk.
Wenn du 1000 Euro spendest, hast du Weihnachten mit den Höckes.
Und dann darfst du ihre Schafe streicheln. Und das ist ein Wochenende,
nämlich Weihnachten bis Silvester in Bornhagen und wir haben den beim Fleiß
aufs Haaren, also so einmal aus der Kiste, wurde der oft gekauft.
Aber nicht einmal eingelöst.
Das habe ich mich für wundernd gefühlt.
Fünf oder zehn Leute haben das gekauft. Weihnachten bei den Höckes.
Nichts anderes dabei. Kein Shirt dabei, nix. Also apropos Shirt,
da hast du auch gleich was zu verkünden.
Aber dann fragt man sich, okay, cool, die nächsten zehn Jahre sind ausgebucht,
muss man gleich auf Booking kommen, auf ausgebucht stellen und bei Airbnb.
Und dann melden die sich einfach nicht mehr.
Frechheit, oder? Für 1000 Euro Weihnachten bei den Höckes gebucht und dann sind die no show.
Und ihr steht da mit dem Kelleleiter da.
Alles schon bereitet.
Schafe gefangen.
Kommt nicht. Gast. Weg nicht. No show.
100 Prozent.
Haben die Höckes da inzwischen ne Wand gebaut oder sowas?
Nö, das ist ein Maschendrahtzern.
Die gucken da jeden Tag drauf, ja?
Ja, Maschendrahtzern. Du kannst auch keine Wand, das ist nicht zulässig.
Also das Mahnmal darf da ja stehen,
weil ja Denkmäler bis vier Meter Höhe zulassungsfrei sind in Thüringen.
Aber in Zahlen zwischen dir und deinem Nachbarn, in welchen Drahtzellen,
das Nachbarschaftsrecht. Zwei Meter. Mehr ist nicht. Zwei Meter.
Also wie viele Jahre ist diese Aktion jetzt her?
Boah, jetzt okay, kein Scherz, Google.
Wahrscheinlich 5, 6 Jahre inzwischen würde ich denken.
Ich würde meinen auch, warte mal, ich muss das tatsächlich… 22.
November 2017.
Genau, dann waren wir danach beim Kongress.
6 Jahre, ja.
Dann waren wir danach beim Kongress. War das nicht CCH sogar noch?
Ja und wieder.
Es war jetzt gleichzeitig ein Ja und ein Nee.
17? Nee, 17 war Leipzig. 17, 18, 19 war Leipzig.
34, C3, Leipzig, ja.
Tja, dann waren wir vielleicht damit doch nicht beim Kongress.
Wir waren nämlich mit dem öffentlichen Begräbnis, also damit waren wir.
Die Toten kommen.
Genauso war der Titel. Und vorher waren wir beim MCCH, was ich ja übrigens geiler fand.
Ich finde es auch mega geil, dass es wieder ins CCH jetzt zurück geht.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie das dann nach der Sanierung aussieht,
aber die Messe Leipzig, das war halt auf der Bühne da,
zumindest so mein Feeling, da hab ich mich gefühlt wie so der Vorstandsvorsitzende
von Volkswagen bei der Aktionärskonferenz, was auch ein geiles Feeling ist.
So mit diesem Licht und diesen riesigen Tribünen, die da aufgebaut waren.
Aber es war halt so Messehalle-mäßig so, ne?
Ja.
Und im CCH damals, das war so wie in so einem alten Kino vor der Leinwand zu
sitzen, so wie so ein Ich bespreche meinen Film.
Irgendwie so, das war halt total
familiär und so weiter und das war ja tatsächlich auch, muss man sagen,
war das für uns der Startschuss, weil wir da unsere ersten, ich weiß nicht wie
viele, aber so Fördermitgliedschaften an den Mann und an die Frau und an alle
gebracht haben, an die Menschen.
Weil ja kurz später letztlich so, wir waren ganz am Anfang bei Kulturförderung
und haben dort Gelder abgegrast, wo es halt ging.
Aber natürlich ist es mittlerweile den meisten Theatern zu riskant mit uns zusammenzuarbeiten
und deswegen ist sowas… Das erregt auch öffentliches Interesse.
Ja und subversive Kunst ist letztlich was, was man nicht dauerhaft über den
Staat finanzieren kriegt und dieser erste CCC-Vortrag,
waren halt, das waren weiß ich nicht wie viele, aber es waren vielleicht die
ersten 500 Fördermitglieder, die wir gemacht haben.
Damals haben wir gesagt, ja
tausend brauchen wir und die haben wir ja mittlerweile sogar mehr als die.
Und jetzt ist so immer, also so subversive Aktionskunst, kannst du nicht kaufen, aber bezahlen.
Das ist genauso wie bei uns. Genau.
Aber wo wir bezahlen, ihr wollt doch auch noch was das hier bezahlen.
Ich wollte erstmal mein Geschenk haben.
Achso, geil. Ich schenke jetzt hier, kann man auch übrigens kaufen auf unserer
Website, Wer noch kein Weihnachtsgeschenk für die Mutti in Sachsen hat.
Wir haben das Verbotsquartett des Jahres und das Verbotsspiel des Jahres 2023,
nämlich einmal AfD-Verbotsquartett von Olaf Scholz persönlich präsentiert und,
einmal das Original afdverbot.de Skatblatt.
Das ist ein wirklich schönes Spiel.
Für die langweiligen Tage 25.12. Damit kann man so richtig den Familienfrieden in Sachsen zerstören.
Ja und beim Skaten, also ich befreie das mal.
Ich hab ein Spiel dabei, legst du nicht nur Weihnachtsabend mit dem Onkel,
ich hab ein Skatblatt dabei.
Skatblatt, ja und da sind natürlich dann die Bauern und Könige und die Damen,
kann man sich ungefähr vorstellen, welche Gesichter die haben bei dem Skatblatt.
Du hast Höcke, Weidel, Gauland, Ass.
Und beim Quartett?
Komm, wir spielen eine Runde Quartett. Jeder eine Karte. Ich fang an.
Ja, du hast auch hier eine Karte.
Ja, tu ihn selber. Nimmst du ab.
Ich muss jetzt so zufällig eine ziehen.
Nimm dir irgendeine.
Ich ziehe irgendeine Karte.
Ich hab Matthias Helferich, also Helferich Matthias, der Helferich Matthias
und ich nehm Verbotometer, wer hat die höchste? Ich hab 99 Prozent.
99%!
99% ist fast ganz verboten.
Was? Ich hab nur 91%.
Ich hab auch nur 91%, ich hab Alice Weidel.
Ich auch.
Man muss dazu sagen, bei dem Spiel hat jedes, das sind ja alles hier AfD-Funktionäre, die haben,
halt Verbotometer, Demokratiefeindlichkeit, Beweismenge gegen sie und Mitgliedsnummer drauf.
Und wir haben aber gesagt beim Verbotometer, dass jedes AfD-Mitglied so ein
Grundeinkommen kriegt, ein bedingungsloses quasi.
Das heißt, allein dafür, dass du Mitglied oder Funktionär bist,
hast du schon mal 60 Prozent.
Und der Rest ist dann ein komplizierter Algorithmus, aus dem sich dann… Also
was misst denn das Verbotometer?
Wie sehr man verbieten sollte?
Naja genau, nee es ist ein Mist. Tatsächlich ist es ein empirischer Wert,
denn er setzt sich zusammen aus den Mengen an Beweisen, dazu kommen wir später
in Tiefe, die wir gegen die Person gesammelt haben auf unserer Webseite und
des Schweregrades des Beweises.
Und das Ganze dann mit einem Cap bei 100.
Du hast da einen mit 99 Prozent. Wie heißt der?
Matthias Hilfereich. Ich leg den mal in die Mitte, dann können wir uns den nachher
mal in der Tiefe angucken, wenn wir über die Webseite und die Beweise reden.
Ich hab aber einen gefunden, der den Stich tastet. Das ist der Hans-Thomas Tilsch.
Der hat Verbotometer 100.
Ja, das heißt?
37 Beweise, 96 Prozent demokratiefeindlich.
Fünf Sterne. Das ist eine der besten Karten im ganzen Land.
Ja, der ist auch eine andere Farbe, ne?
Und das ist der demokratiefeindlichste AfD-Party.
Da kommen auch noch die größten Honks zu richtiger Werke dazu.
Björn Höcke habe ich hier, 100.
Oh Höcke, ja gut. Das ist natürlich klar, dass das auch ein Ass in dem Spiel ist.
So, das war das Gastgeschenk von mir.
Vielen vielen Dank.
Und so ein Ding habe ich auch noch für euch. Wie habt ihr das gerade genannt,
dieses ähm, wie sagt ihr zu Jutebeutel noch?
Raumbildendes Packmaß.
Habe ich auch noch für euch dabei. Das hab ich auch noch dabei.
Mit, auch mit, aber ohne Alkohol.
Aber das ist erst, wenn ich ein drittes Bier krieg.
Kriegst du.
Nein, ich hab das noch nicht mal angefangen bis heute.
Wir haben halt hier gerade im Vorgespräch natürlich die große Merch-Show gemacht,
weil Stefan kommt rein und knallt erstmal ein Quartett und ein Skat-Deck auf den Tisch.
Wir haben ja auch ein neues raumbildendes Parkmitte.
Haben wir, ja. Ja und Tim hat das wieder ohne mich gemacht und ich verstehe
auch genau wieso, weil ich hätte nein gesagt und es ist gut geworden.
Das ist immer dann, wenn Tim was ohne mir abzusprechen macht.
Du weißt doch, was ich dir, zitier ich tatsächlich relativ oft,
wie du die Rakete, die Fairydust gekauft hast oder organisiert hast fürs Camp
und es niemandem gesagt hast, weil du wusstest, wenn du eine Frage sagst, alle sind bescheuert,
wir geben doch nicht irgendwie so unsere 4000 Mark für eine GFK Rakete aus.
Ja, wir haben Datenelch-Shirts, T-Shirts mit Datenelch,
der,
uns gezeichnet wurde von Krimp, gleicher Zeichner wie auch das Logbuch Netzpolitik
Einhorn Standarten Einhorn.
Und ja, es ist ein Datenelch, erkennbarer Elch im Cartoon-Style und mit allen möglichen Antennen.
Ich sehe 2G-Antennen, ich sehe Fernseh-Antennen, ich sehe Mikrowellen,
Richtfunk.
Der Datenelch ist mit allem ausgestattet, um auch noch die entlegensten Gebiete
Deutschlands und Brandenburgs zu versorgen. Genau.
Das ist ja Hintergrund der Story.
Schöne Grüße an Klößen... wie heißt das?
Klößenger... ich weiß nicht. Groß Klößengerne?
Groß Kürres?
Ne, dieses Dorf 5 Meter hinter der Berliner Stadtgrenze.
Das gar kein Internet hat.
Ja, wo sie dann groß gesagt haben, wir bauen mal welches hin.
Und dann kommen die Leute... Klößengörne.
Klößengörne, das war es. Genau.
Und da gibt's bis heute nix oder was?
Ich glaube, die haben noch das Angebot bekommen, einen zu bekommen und dann
haben sie das abgelehnt, glaube ich, auch noch wegen Strahlung.
Das ist eine Bürgerinitiative gegen den Urp.
Ja, da ist dann irgendeinem ein Felderkrankung.
Ja, also, Gläsengörner ist nicht mehr… Die wollen Kupfer. Deswegen,
du kannst da nur mit einem Datenelche überhaupt irgendwas erreichen,
weil die sich einfach durch die Bälder durch… Ja, bis sich da die Bürgerinitiative
gegründet hat, ist der schon weiter längst, das Datenelche.
Datenelche sind einfach überall.
Ja, mega geil sieht er aus, der Daten-Elch, finde ich. T-Shirts kaufen und Raum bilden.
Und vor allem das Beste an diesem T-Shirt ist, also nicht nur,
weil sowas mache ich ja generell nicht, also nicht nur ist da keine URL drauf,
steht auch sonst nichts drauf.
Es ist einfach nur der Daten-Elch, es ist nur for those who know,
es ist einfach ein wunderschönes T-Shirt. Ihr müsst diesmal nicht mal Werbeträger sein.
Perfektes Weihnachtsgeschenk.
Finde ich halt auch.
Perfekte Weihnachtsgeschenk.
Vor allem für Leute, die Logboten-Headspeed-Fig nicht kennen oder hören, ist auch was dabei.
Guck mal hier ein Datenschirm, ein süßes Hemd.
Die machen wir gleich auf eine Tasse auch noch drauf. Auch noch? Ja, klar.
Stefan kennt sich ganz gut aus, was man so für ein Zeug...
Schlüsselanhänger ist gut, Feuerzeug ist gut.
Mir wurde gesagt, Socken würden gehen, aber ich bin...
Doch, die gehen, die gehen ab. Ja, ja, da kannst du auch...
Socken?
Dankeschön.
Eher als Geschenk, oder?
Ich hab ja tatsächlich mal neulich gegoogelt, die zehn wichtigsten Weihnachtsgeschenke.
Man kann sich jetzt selber denken, warum? Und dann die ersten sind dann so Parfum,
wo du denkst, okay, ja, das ist, weil das halt jemand seinem Partner schickt.
Aber ein AfD-Parfum kriegt ja jeder in Berlin auf der Straße.
Alice, du weißt ja, du wärst ein gutes Alice.
Naja, und dann, da ist auf jeden Fall dabei Bücher, aber dann kommen Klamotten,
also Shirts, ganz vorne mit dabei und dann ganz schnell Quartettspiele.
Jaja, Spiele sind auch sowas, was man unter den Weihnachtsbaum legt tatsächlich.
Ja, kann man nochmal so einen mit beiwerfen.
Da müssen wir aber noch mehr Charaktere hier erfinden bei Logos und Herzpolitik,
um ein ganzes Quartett vollzukommen.
Ihr müsst Gäste einfach, die ihr habt hier.
Das ist eine geile Idee. Und die bewerben dann nach Kreativität, Humor und so.
Demokratie, Feindlichkeit, schlecht. Aber Humor.
Super.
Aber gab es schon, weil ihr braucht 32 Karten, also ihr habt ein Deckblatt,
eine Karte, dann braucht ihr 32 Karten.
32 Gäste haben wir, weil dann regen sich natürlich alle auf,
wenn wir dann irgendwie so ein Scoring machen.
Ja, das stimmt. Ihr hattet 32 Gäste in 477 Sendungen.
Also ihr hattet dann, würde ich schon schätzen, ja.
Ich kann mal nachgucken, wie viel Grad.
0,25. Wie viele Gäste pro Sendung sind das?
Wir machen ja selten Gäste. Das ist schon eine besondere Ehre, die der.
Das stimmt.
473. Also ihr habt 0,06 Gäste pro Sendung. Ja.
Wenn ihr in 32, ah ne, ihr habt ja mehr als 32 Gäste.
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich bin gerade auf der Suche.
Frag mal Shitty Info oder so.
Ich krieg das hier schon zusammen, Sekunde.
Ja, was empfiehlst du denn noch zum Verschenken?
Oh, wir haben noch mal 32.
Was kam denn da als nächstes? Also es kam dann irgendwann ziemlich schnell das
Buch und da war viel Videospiel, Fernsehkram dabei und Gutscheine.
Gutscheine sind auch super.
Gutscheine könnt ihr uns… Aber ihr könnt natürlich einfach entweder jemandem
quasi das Datenelch T-Shirt schenken oder ihr schenkt ihm oder ihr einen Gutschein,
für das Datenelch T-Shirt.
Ja, das, guck mal, da haben wir schon zwei.
Zwei gute Weihnachtsgeschenke. Zwei Top Ten Weihnachtsgeschenke.
Das eine ist sofort vermögenswirksam negativ, das andere erst dann,
wenn die Person es einlöst sozusagen. Das ist ja das Geile am Gutschein.
Also nicht so ein Gutschein von der Jet-Tankstelle, da fahren die Leute sofort
zur Jet-Tankstelle, aber wenn du jemandem einen Gutschein schenkst,
hier ein Wochenende mit mir in So- Achso, ja, den Trick hab ich auch schon öfter
gemacht, als wir die einfach mal eingelistet haben.
Alpaka-Wanderung hab ich mal
mit jemandem diskutiert und ich glaub es wird irgendwann bald eingelöst.
Sagen wir es mal so. Also Werbeblog für's T-Shirt haben wir.
Haben wir auch, ja. Ist dann verlinkt?
Wir machen auch ein Foto davon, ne? Oder können wir das Motiv irgendwie in die
Shownotes machen oder so, dass man das sieht? Kann man einfach so kaufen, ist ja ein Podcast.
Ja, ja, kommt da schon rein.
Kann man ruhig einfach kaufen ohne das zu sehen.
Also wir haben locker, ich glaub über 100 Gäste sogar gehabt.
Nein.
Doch. Und wir haben ziemlich genau 32, die mindestens zweimal da waren.
Das kann man nämlich auch, aber wenn der Wert entweder eins oder zwei ist,
ist es natürlich schlecht beim Quartett. Wie oft war er da? 100 Gäste kommen
überhaupt nicht ins Laden.
100 mal Gäste vielleicht, aber nicht… Nein, 100 unterschiedliche Gäste.
Ich bin diese Liste durchgegangen.
Und hast du auch mit deinen Fingern mitgezählt?
Nicht nur mit meinen Fingern, auch mit meinem Kopf. Und das ist so.
Jede vierte Sendung ein Gast.
Ja, also bei Thomas und bei Andre weiß ich nicht, ob die wirklich als Gäste
zählen, aber die habe ich jetzt auch gar nicht als Gäste gezählt tatsächlich.
Ja, dann haben wir hier Felix Reda achtmal, siebenmal Constanze Kurz,
siebenmal Kathrin, fünfmal Frank Krieger, Markus Reuter, Ulf Böhmeier,
Geriere, Anne Wenzel, Anne Semsreuth, Daniel Kröger, Benjamin Bergemann,
Herr Schrimpe, Gregor Sedlak, Philipp Otto, Katharina Nokun.
Da haben wir bald unser Quartett, haben wir bald unsere 100.
Max Schrems zweimal, John F. Nebel zweimal, Raik Anders zweimal und so weiter.
Maria Reimer, Domscheit-Berg.
Du entwertest hier meine Anwesenheit gerade.
In so einer illustren Runde.
Ach stimmt, nee, du aufwertest sie.
Hans-Christian Ströbele.
Da gehörst du jetzt zu diesen 100.
Club.
Verstehst du? Da gibt's dann später auch so einen Ausweis und so,
den kannst du dann vorzeigen.
Und ich bin im Quartett dabei. Wenn eins kommt.
Wenn ein zweites Mal kommt.
Wenn ich ein zweites Mal komme, bin ich im Quartett dabei. Dann komm ich nochmal.
Mal gucken. Nächstes Jahr haben wir schon wieder so heimelige Rundezahlen,
die wir anstreben bei unserer Sendungsreihe.
Gucken wir mal was. Da geht's.
So wollen wir mal mit der Sendung anfangen. Jetzt kommen wir doch mal zu deinem
aktuellen Projekt oder eurem aktuellen Projekt.
Wie viele Leute haben daran mitgewirkt? Kannst du das sagen oder ist das geheim?
Ne, zu viele. Ist nicht geheim, aber es ist halt zu viele, die ich sagen könnte,
weil ihr müsst das sehen, dass wir mittlerweile ein ganz schöner Bürokratie-Monster sind.
Also ich würde jetzt sagen, intern mindestens 30, die da bei uns irgendwas gemacht
haben und extern, dann hast du noch Video-Leute.
Eine Firma hat da was aufgebaut, das könnte ich jetzt nicht beziffern,
aber irgendwo 30 plus externe Leute und da sind ja auch die Programmierer und so weiter mit drin.
Haben viele mitgewirkt und diesmal haben wir uns unseren Stammkunden eigentlich
wieder gewidmet, weil das ZPS so über die Jahre beobachtet hat,
hat gesehen, dass es ein Kunde uns
besonders angetan hat und das ist die Parteialternative für Deutschland.
Und wir fragen uns oftmals, ja was machen wir jetzt und so weiter und am Ende
haben wir gesagt, ach komm, die AfD ist eine sichere Bank,
da hat man Spaß dran, die reagieren noch, wir hatten mal früher was gegen,
was ist gegen, wir machen ja immer was mit den Leuten, mit der CSU gemacht,
haben die nicht reagiert und so weiter.
Und die AfD, das ist todsicher, da hast du deine Abmahnung, da hast du ganze
Vorplanen quasi, da hast du nicht Anwaltsgeld umsonst irgendwie rausgegeben
oder so, weil du sicher deine Reaktion kriegst. So, diesmal haben wir eine...
Eine Geschichte gemacht. Erstmal natürlich eine Website, die heißt afd-verbot.de.
Und die ganze Sache hat ein paar Elemente. Auf unserer Website afd-verbot.de,
haben wir ein Video produziert, denn das fing alles vor einer Weile damit an,
dass wir uns überlegt haben, okay, wir machen also diese AfD-Verbotsgeschichte,
aber wer ist hier so der, wer ist so, das ZBS arbeitet ja oft mit so einem Heiligen
oder mit so jemandem, der eine Person ist, in die man was rein projiziert.
Und in dem Fall haben wir sehr viel in den Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz rein interpretiert.
Und das war für uns jetzt so aus künstlerischer Sicht spannend,
weil Olaf Scholz ja jemand ist, der nicht so sehr für so mitreißende Momente
bekannt ist und für so Hauruck-Geschichten.
Das ist mir noch gar nicht aufgefallen.
Aber du hast gerade was ganz tolles gehört.
Der kann sogar Humor. Wir haben dann gesagt, ja ab und zu leuchtende Momente,
ganz kurze leuchtende Momente, aber dann kriegst du wieder so einen ganz monotonen,
also es ist auf jeden Fall jemand, wo du sagst, wow, der ist echt nordisch,
also das ist eigentlich die Personifizierung dieses nordischen.
Das ist eine Hanseat.
Wir haben gesagt, wir wollen jetzt in den Reihen produzieren und projektieren die beste Rede.
Die er nie gehalten hat. Und kam dann relativ schnell neulich,
war ihm das Thema überall, oh Deepfakes kommen, um Gottes willen,
alles wird jetzt gedeepfaked, glaub gar nichts mehr und so weiter.
Und wir haben dann gesagt, oh geil, jetzt kann man einfach mal ein Deepfake
mal ganz einfach produzieren und es war ein Höllenritt, zu irgendeinem halbwegs
vernünftigen Ergebnis zu kommen, von dem jetzt alle schreien,
oh, ganz schlimmer Deepfake.
Wo wir sagen, okay, das war gerade so, das war wirklich das unterste Level,
das ging bis zur letzten Sekunde und es war das unterste Level,
wo wir gesagt haben, wir waren kurz davor, den Scholz ganz rauszuschneiden im
Video, weil wir gesagt haben, eigentlich ist das nicht gut genug.
So, aber um zurück zu diesem Umreißenden zu kommen, haben wir also gesagt,
AfD-Verbot, Scholz hält eine Rede und es ist die Rede seiner Amtszeit,
es ist die Rede zur Lage der Nation, es ist wirklich die Zeitenwende.
Denn wir haben eine Partei im Deutschen Bundestag, hinter der sich die gesamte
rechtsextreme Szene der Bundesrepublik versammelt hat.
Es gibt heute faktisch keine NPD mehr, es sind nur noch fünf Idioten und alle,
der gesamte Potenzial der rechtsextremen Szene hat sich hinter einer Partei
versammelt und auch diese Partei unterwandert.
Sie ist konsequent nach rechts gerückt und wir haben gesagt.
Scholz hält jetzt die Rede und weist darauf hin, wir machen jetzt das AfD-Verbot,
ich reiche das ein zum fünften Todestag von Walter Lübcke und ich brauche aber
eure Hilfe, denn, das kommt im Video nicht, aber wir haben gesagt,
damals beim NPD-Verbotsverfahren wurde ja gesagt,
Okay, alles gut, die sind auf jeden Fall total verfassungsrechtlich.
Aber die V-Leute waren...
Aber die sind voll unterwandert, der Verfassungsschutz...
Der ganze Laden wird vom Verfassungsschutz gemanagt.
Du weißt nicht mehr, welches Zitat kommt jetzt eigentlich von der Behörde und
welches Verfahren kommt wirklich aus der Partei.
Weil sie Angst hatten, die Behörde zu verbieten, haben sie gedacht.
Oder weil sie dann gescheitert werden. Hö, das hat ja die Behörde gesagt.
Das ist ja gar nicht von...
Das ist aber auch schon wieder lange her, das NPD-Verbotsverfahren.
Lange, ja.
Da wurde angestrebt, die NPD zu verbieten und das ist wirklich gescheitert.
Das ist zweimal gescheitert, das ist zweidoppelt gescheitert.
Erste Scheiterung war, zu viel Verfassungsschutz in der Partei und dann ist
es nochmal gescheitert.
Wegen Irrelevanz?
Nee, genau, weil die Partei halt irrelevant ist. Also da wurde gesagt,
die Partei ist zwar rechtsextrem, auch gesichert,
aber sie hat halt keine Chance, in der Wahl irgendwas zu reißen und bei,
also Scholz wollte jetzt bei uns zumindest,
in unserem Drehbuch diesen Fehler nicht machen und hat gesagt deswegen,
Bitte liebe Bevölkerung, gebt uns Hinweise.
Wenn ihr irgendwas kennt, wenn ihr verfassungsfeindliche Bestrebungen kennt,
meldet die mir, mir Olaf,
unter meiner Website und dann kann ich die aufnehmen in die Datenbank.
Die Datenbank, die es gibt, auf afd-verbot.de, da,
haben wir natürlich vorrecherchiert mit einem Rechercheteam.
Allein das waren acht Leute, die zwei Monate gearbeitet haben,
alle Quellen ausgewertet haben.
Und dort sind jetzt schon 350 circa Personen erfasst und denen sind 1500 Zitate
zugeordnet. Kann man sich angucken, afd-verbot.de.
Kein Zitat ist falsch, alles öffentliche Quellen, alles mit einer Quelle referenziert
und kategorisiert und man kann quasi in die Beweise reingehen.
Da wünschen sich, direkt auf der Startseite übrigens, Bürgerkriegszustände und
das sind alles Originalquellen aus der AfD.
Und jetzt weiß ich auch was die empirische Datenbasis für dieses Quartett ist.
Genau, das ist die Datenbank. Also die Daten, diese Punkte aus dem Quartett,
speisen sich. Genau, du kannst suchen.
Du kannst übrigens nach Bürgerkrieg suchen, du kannst auch nach Personen suchen.
Dann gehst du in Alice Weidel rein, die hat gesagt, diese Schweine sind nichts
anderes als Marionetten der Siegermächte des Zweiten Weltkriegs und haben die
Aufgabe, das deutsche Volk klein zu halten, indem molekulare Bürgerkriege in
den Ballungszentren durch Überfremdung induziert werden.
Das haben wir kategorisiert als Leugnung der Legitimität einer demokratisch gewählten Regierung.
Demokratiefeindlichkeit, Versuch der Ausbürgerung von Menschen.
Und das hat die in ZDF gesagt?
Das hat die in ZDF frontal, ist die Quelle. Also genau, wir beziehen uns hier
immer auf eine Quelle und haben quasi öffentlich zugängliches Material ausgewertet
und das halt in extremer Kleinarbeit den Personen zugeordnet, wie sie sind.
Dann gibt es einen Mugshot von jeder Person, der ist KI generiert.
Also Mugshot ist ein Verhaftungsfoto, was man so… Das typische amerikanische Bild.
Und das ist natürlich eine Persiflage, denn ein Parteiverbot bedeutet ja nicht die Verhaftung,
sondern eigentlich ist es der Entzug der staatlichen Zuwendung,
der Verbot der Organisation und der Einzug quasi jeglicher Mittel.
Und ich bin persönlich, das sage ich jetzt mal ganz persönlich,
ich bin nicht jemand, der Parteiverbote gut fand und ich bin auch sogar jemand,
der beim NPD-Verbotsverfahren auch gesagt hat, das bringt ja alles nichts,
weil das waren nur ein paar Versprengte.
Heute ist die Situation aber eine andere, dass ich sage, Leute,
das ist wirklich eine Partei, die machen das komplett mit staatlichen Mitteln,
machen jetzt nur eine politische Stiftung,
in deren Fraktionen arbeiten militante Rechtsextremisten und die zwacken Geld
vom Steuerzahler ab und finanzieren damit rechtsextreme Umtriebe.
Grenzen sich null ab gegen irgendwas und das ist wirklich gefährlich und meiner
Meinung nach sollte dafür für solche Äußerungen, die wirklich gegen die Prinzipien
von unserer Verfassung verstoßen, kein Steuergeld fließen.
Ja, das ist,
und zumal sich ja auch ein bisschen die Frage stellt, wie geht das weiter?
Wo geht's hin und wann ist der Moment? Also alle sagen ja, bei der AfD,
das ist auch ein interessanter Punkt aus dem Verfassungsschutzding von damals
mit der NPD, dass man sagt, ja die sind zwar total verfassungsfeindlich,
aber die sind zu klein, um sie zu verbieten.
Genau, das ist hier jetzt nicht unbedingt der Fall.
Das Ding ist halt, wo ist dann dieser Moment, also es gibt ja dann,
jetzt haben wir ja gerade den Moment, dass es schon schwierig ist zu sagen,
Leute, das ist eine 20%-Partei, die kannst du nicht verbieten.
Wann kann man dir denn was verbieten?
Genau, gibt's irgendwo, kann ich irgendwo im großen Atlas für Staatsrecht mal
kurz nachlesen, wann dieser Prozentpunkt genau ist, bevor die Partei zu groß
ist, aber wenn sie nicht noch zu klein ist.
Das ist ja vor allem nicht das Kriterium. Das Kriterium ist ja,
verstößt sie gegen die Verfassung.
Ja und es ist natürlich auch nicht Olaf Scholz, der sagt, ich werde sie verbieten,
aber nein, eigentlich sagt er, ich stelle einen Verbotsantrag.
Und gerne, im Moment ist der Verbotsantrag blockiert, denn den kann die Bundesregierung
stellen, den kann auch der Bundestag, der Bundesrat und die Bundesregierung.
Einer von dreien kann nach Karlsruhe gehen, einen Antrag einreichen und das Verbot beantragen.
Und du Linus kannst es nicht, ich auch nicht.
Und im Moment weigern sich alle drei Instanzen das zu tun.
Und dann sagt man, nee, man darf ja nicht die andere Partei verbieten.
Aber das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt ja nicht, du verbietest die jetzt hier
Olaf oder Linus, Wobei du ja gar nichts sagst.
Sondern er sagt, okay, ich hab den Antrag angenommen, ich prüfe das.
So wie ich jetzt sagen könnte, ich zeig dich an, ich zeig dich an,
du bist, ich hab gesehen, der Linus ist zu schnell mit seinem Moped um die Ecke
gefahren, dann wird der Beweis aufgenommen und irgendwann gibt's ein Gericht, das prüft das.
Das kann ich, ich kann Linus anpfeifen, sozusagen, weil er immer zu schnell...
Komm ich aber nicht ins Gefängnis.
Wegen dem nicht, aber ich muss die Strafe zahlen, genau. Aber ich kann dich
halt wegen irgendwas denunzieren. Denunzieren eigentlich.
Und jetzt wegen Verfassungsfeindlichkeit können nur diese drei Instanzen und
dann würde das Verfassungsgericht prüfen und sagen ja oder nein.
Und ich finde doch, dass diese Prüfung jetzt langsam an der Zeit ist,
denn entweder ist die Partei,
nicht verfassungsfeindlich, dann wird sie diese Prüfung überstehen und quasi
dann ist sie erlaubt weiterhin oder sie ist eben doch verfassungsfeindlich wie
ich meine und dann würde sie verboten das ist.
Das ist der Grund und wir hätten die irgendwann ausreichende also beide sobald
die irgendeine regierungsbeteiligung hätten oder eine ausreichende Mehrheit im Bundesrat,
dann kann man quasi gar nicht mehr verboten werden?
Irgendwann ist es, wenn du selber die Legislatur... dann wird es irgendwann schwierig.
Also wenn du in einer Regierung bist, dann... es gibt auch...
Du stellst dann irgendwann... du berufst ja auch irgendwann Verfassungsrichter.
Dann trifft alles in den Regierungs... Das heißt, ich glaube tatsächlich,
wenn es einen Moment gibt, der noch vernünftig ist, dann ist der bald gekommen.
Und zwar am 4. Juni 2024. So, das grundsätzlich erstmal zu dieser Verbotsthematik.
So und wir haben dann, also das ist das eine, was wir gemacht haben,
nämlich in den Scholz diese Hoffnungsfigur rein projiziert.
Gleichzeitig ist aber auch auf dubiosem Wege, muss man sagen,
ganz schlechter Datenschutz bei der AfD,
Alice Weidel persönlich hat
uns aus Versehen ihre Mitgliederliste übermittelt und dann aus Versehen?
Aus Versehen, ja sie hat die ausgedruckt und aber also wir haben von Alice Weidel
die Mitgliederliste der AfD bekommen,
die ist mittlerweile gelöscht natürlich, Aber wir haben das dann genutzt,
um uns an die Mitglieder der AfD persönlich zu wenden und haben denen einen Brief geschickt,
in dem wir quasi eine Fristsache ankündigen.
Denn laut dem Parteitagsbeschluss, Moment, Brief,
der Brief, so, der Brief lautet so, wir vom Bundesvorstand wenden uns direkt
an Sie, weil unsere Partei großen Gefahren ausgesetzt ist.
Nach unseren jüngsten Wahlerfolgen streben einige Altparteien im Verbund mit
linksextremen Kräften nichts weniger als ein Verbot unserer Partei an.
Das muss verhindert werden.
Der Bundesvorstand hat deshalb auf dem Parteitag in Magdeburg den Antrag Verbot
verhindern Indizien sichten.
Nach § 11 Bundessatzung eingebracht und dafür eine breite Mehrheit enthalten.
Der Punkt ist, die Leute sollten auf unsere Website gehen www.afdbund.de,
denn.
Die AfD Die hat die Domains AfD, AfD direkt, AfD minus direkt, AfD minus Bund.
Aber AfD-Bund haben wir.
Darum haben wir also quasi gesagt, ihr müsst jetzt auf die Webseite AfD-Bund,
gehen und dort dann quasi alle eure, alles was ihr an rechtsextremem Material habt,
uns zur Sichtung schicken, damit wir bewerten können, ob das uns gefährlich werden kann.
Und seitdem laufen die Uploads. Wir haben jetzt 33 Gigabyte bisher bekommen,
also wir haben viel mehr, wir haben 750 Gigabyte bekommen, aber diverse Algorithmen,
diverses Ding haben uns den Rest entledigt.
Und jetzt haben wir noch 33 Gigabyte übrig und sind da in der Sichtung wunderbares
Material dabei, interne Chatgruppen, Terminkalender sind dabei,
komplette Exporte und so weiter.
Und das sichten wir, das ist viel zu sichten und schwierig zu sichten,
um dann quasi weiter daraus ermitteln zu können und unsere Webseite weiter zu füttern und natürlich,
wo wir überfordert sind mit der Bewertung, vielleicht das Ganze auch an Medien weiterzugeben.
Kann man den Brief irgendwo, ist der irgendwo online? Können wir den?
Der wird, jetzt ist er noch nicht online, aber der wird sehr bald.
Da muss man dann die Links dazu.
Ich will ja nichts vorwegnehmen, aber wir machen gerade wieder ein kleines Video.
Das kommt, glaube ich, Montag.
Wie viele von diesen Briefen habt ihr verschickt?
20.000,
Ja, und da ist das Problem mit dir. Ja, ja, das ist viel, ne?
Und wenn du 20.000 Briefe verschickst bei der Post, dann musst du auch recht
aufpassen, wie machst du das genau und so weiter und so fort und was für einen
Post-Service nimmst du, wie kriegst du noch einen Discount hin und so weiter.
Genau, aber wurde verschickt und wir kriegen halt sehr viel Rücklauf.
Wir kriegen übrigens auch, das ist das Lustigste, auch Rücklauf per Post.
Also es gibt Leute, die schreiben dann, sie sind überfordert damit,
leider jetzt hier ihren Chat zu exportieren, das ist alles nicht so.
Ich schicke euch dann einen Brief.
Teilweise handgeschrieben mit was ihre Beobachtungen sind. Wenden sie sich an
die Sichtungskommission.
Warum steht da oben auf dem Brief herzlichen Glückwunsch?
Ja weil es Dialogpost, bei Dialogpost, wenn du einen günstigeren Posttarif machen
willst, dann muss oben herzlichen Glückwunsch stehen.
Da muss oben herzlichen Glückwunsch, weil du musst die Leute beglückwünschen
und sie haben an einem Gewinnspiel gewonnen, dann bist du bei Dialogpost. Erstens.
Zweitens, unten, das ist vielleicht noch ganz interessant, sofern sich aus ihrer
Einsendung relevante Hinweise und Erkenntnisse für die weitere Arbeit ergeben,
ist die Kommission befugt, sie bis einschließlich 12.2025 von Mitgliedsbeiträgen zu befreien.
Unter allen Teilnehmern verlost der Bundesvorstand als kleine Gegenleistung
außerdem dreimal ein Wochenende für zwei Personen zum ältesten Weihnachtsmarkt
in Deutschland, den Dresdner Striezelmarkt sowie 10 Tankgutscheine im Wert von 50 Euro.
In Klammern JET. Der Rechtsweg ist ausgeschlossen.
Der Rechtsweg ist ausgeschlossen, ja.
Genau. So, das ging dann hier raus, das war noch bevor wir überhaupt an den
Start gegangen sind, um das mal chronologisch einzuordnen. Das sind die Posts.
Wir haben dann wegen... Es ist so, dass ich der Meinung bin,
wir dürfen das. Ich bin ja immer auch der Meinung, wir dürfen das.
Aber es gab die Befürchtung in unserer rechtlichen Vertretung,
dass es die Gegenseite nicht so sieht wie wir. Also dass wir das dürfen.
Was meine Gegenseite? Ich dachte eure Mitspieler.
Naja genau, die anderen Akteure auf der Bühne.
Und dass sie Zweifel dran haben könnten, ob wir das so genau dürfen,
vor allem diese AfD-Bund-Seite.
Und dann hat man das so geschickt, dann hat man sich vom Anwalt ausrechnen lassen,
wie lang ist man mindestens online. Das war eine Information,
die hat uns nicht gefallen.
Also wenn die Gegenseite perfekt durchgreift, ich kriege das sofort,
dann schreibe ich sofort eine Unterlassungsgeschichte, dann gebe ich die kürzestmögliche
Frist, danach gehe ich vor Gericht und dann ist es weg.
Da waren aber drei bis vier Tage. Dann habe ich gedacht, was werden wir Freitag machen?
Ja, nee, dann fünf, sechs Tage, weil du erst mal Samstag, Sonntag nicht an den Briefkasten musst.
Also Frist fängt niemals, alle, die eine Frist bekommen, eure Frist fängt nie am Samstag an.
Und daraufhin hat es dann, wurde es am Donnerstag verschickt,
so dass es Freitag da war, so dass es Samstag, Sonntag wirken konnte.
Da haben wir auch den Großteil quasi an Infos direkt bekommen.
Ist ja, wenn in einer Partei wie der AfD, wenn dir der Bundesvorsitzende sagt,
du lädst jetzt deine Nazi-Chatgruppe bei uns hoch.
Was sollst du denn da als kleines Mitglied machen, außer einfach zu gehorchen sozusagen.
Wie viele Leute haben sich da zurück gemeldet?
Das ist immer noch schwierig zu sagen, wie viele sind echt, wie viele sind nicht.
Es haben sich sehr viele.
Von den Leuten, die wir kontaktiert haben, haben wir so ein Viertel Rücklauf,
also 5.000 rund und wir haben auch jede Menge dadurch.
Dann kam nämlich die AfD und hat, also da kamen ein paar Sachen.
Am Samstag, noch am Wochenende, hat die AfD eine E-Mail verschickt,
tausende, an alle ihre Mitglieder.
Achtung, der politische Gegner versucht, dass wir unsere Nazi-Sachen, ladet nichts hoch da.
Also die AfD hat dann eigentlich gesagt, Vorsicht, ladet eure Nazi-Chats nicht bei denen hoch.
Aber nur an die Mitglieder. Daraufhin haben alle Mitglieder auf Twitter gesagt,
ey, wie, wir sollen nicht auf afdbund.de.
Also haben den Link gestreut, überall in Social Media, sodass noch viel mehr
Leute draufgegangen sind. Und dann gab es so eine rechte Zeitung,
ich glaube die Junge Freiheit war die Erste, die berichtet hat.
Und wir haben uns gedacht, es kann doch gar nicht sein, ihr seid den,
ihr Hauskätzchen-Zeitung.
Ihr könnt doch nicht diesen Link auch noch streuen. Also wir haben selber gar
nicht unser Glück gefasst, wenn du sagst, hey das ist ein Fake,
das ist wie wenn ich sage, hey da ist so Kreditkartenbetrug.
Guck mal, das ist auf der www.kreditkartenbetrug.de Seite, da sollst du nicht
deine Kreditkarte, also du sagst doch, es gibt eine Seite vom Gegner,
bitte wenn sie was bekommt, aber du verlingst das doch nicht auch noch selber.
Und das haben die aber gemacht, auf allen Kanälen, überall.
Die haben auch mehr gemacht.
Man muss doch, also lassen sie sich doch nicht verbieten.
Also schon gar nicht vom Staat und auch nicht vom Common Sense.
Sie haben natürlich auch noch in dem Artikel eine Adresse angegeben.
Via.
Nee, die junge Freiheit.
Ne Adresse, die Website.
Was da im Impressum steht.
Unser Impressum ist, wir produzieren, wir sind ja die Artists for Democracy, AfD, GmbH.
Damit du die Domäne behalten kannst.
Ja, also aus keiner Anerkennung, der geht runter aufs Impressum.
Ja, wir sind halt leider die Art.
Wir haben vor zwei Wochen eine sogenannte Vorratsgesellschaft erworben,
mit der wir unser Kunstprojekt komplett durchführen können. Das ist unsere Produktionsgesellschaft.
Und das sind die AfD, Artists for Democracy GmbH.
Genau, und damit haben wir jetzt auch ein paar Rechte an dem Namen AfD und dürfen
durchaus auch so filmieren und so weiter. Also genau und was man dann jetzt
alles genau darf und was nicht, das werden jetzt die Anwälte untereinander auskaspern.
Punkt aus ist heute, Freitag, haben wir tatsächlich vorab per E-Mail eine Abmahnung,
der Partei Alternative Deutschland für Deutschland von der Rechtsanwaltskanzlei,
Höcker, also der Stammkanzlei bekommen.
Und da waren wir auch wirklich happy, weil wir dürfen das jetzt noch weiter bis zum 6. Dezember.
Unsere Anwälte haben geguckt und haben gesagt, das ist die großzügigste Frist, die sie je erlebt haben.
Demnach haben wir das heute nur kurz angeguckt und haben gedacht, ah ja, Frist ist 6.
Dezember, dann lassen wir uns noch Zeit und werden uns am Dienstag mit dem Inhalt
der Abmahnung auseinandersetzen und dann rechtzeitig zum 6. auf jeden Fall reagieren.
So war das mit der Ralf Höcker natürlich.
Ralf Höcker ist der Stammanwalt, ist ein Medienrechtler und ist der Stammanwalt der AfD.
Für alles, mit dem haben wir schon auf allen Ebenen zu tun gehabt, mit der Kanzlei Höcker.
So, das war dieses Vor, das war sozusagen unser Prolog, so wie ihr hier einen
Prolog macht, haben wir einen kleinen Prolog mit unserem Kunden,
weil wenn du unser bester Kunde bist,
dann hast du es auch verdient, dass die Aktion für dich drei Tage früher losgeht,
als für die allgemeine Öffentlichkeit.
So finden wir es zumindest. Dann ging es Montag los mit dem Video und wir haben
quasi eine Art Gefängnis, die Justizanstalt des Kanzlers, vor das Kanzleramt gebaut,
auf 5x8 Meter quasi so eine Art Käfig und dort wurden durchgehend quasi,
hat Olaf Scholz persönlich die Anklagepunkte verlesen.
Also sagt Olaf Scholz, Beweisstück 324-7.
Weidel, Alice. Und dann kommt Weidel, Alice, das Original, also Original,
wir haben nichts hier gedoktert, also doch außerdem den Olaf halt,
aber die Alice Weidel nicht und den Tino Krupalla nicht und den Alexander Gauland.
Der Alexander Gauland sagt dann, wenn die Franzosen auf Napoleon stolz sein
dürfen und die Engländer auf Churchill,
Dann dürfen die Deutschen ja wohl stolz auf die Leistung der deutschen Soldaten
im Zweiten Weltkrieg sein.
Das läuft da live. Das lief bis gestern in Dauerschleife vorm Kanzleramt.
Da haben wir quasi die Anklageschrift verlesen.
Was heißt läuft vor dem Kanzleramt? Wie sieht das da konkret aus?
Kanzleramt ist ein 5 mal 8 Meter Käfig.
Davor, also fünf Meter, acht Meter breit, fünf Meter hoch.
Da siehst du ein Bild, so sieht es aus. Und da sind quasi vier Leute,
die unserer Meinung nach zur AfD gehören, nämlich Björn Höcke,
Alexander Gauland, Alice Weidel und Stefan Ernst.
Stefan Ernst ist der Mörder von Walter Lübcke und hat der AfD Kassel im Wahlkampf
geholfen und hat dann den hingerichtet.
Und wir haben den da mit, wir zählen den eins zu eins mit zu.
Erschreckend ist übrigens, es gab gerade Wahl in Hessen kürzlich und da hat
die AfD ein super Ergebnis in dem Wahlkreis gehabt, sogar noch, in dem ein AfD-
Wahlkampfhelfer einen CDU-Politiker ermordet hat.
Also eigentlich was, was einen fassungslos dastehen lässt, wo man denkt,
okay, in dem, die kannten den alle, die haben jetzt gemerkt, okay, nix, nix da.
So, genau, das war, jetzt haben wir das Gefängnis gehabt, weiter geht's.
War das ein Problem, diesen Platz da zu akquirieren von dem Kanzleramt?
Weil ich meine, jetzt einfach mal so was vom Kanzleramt aufstellen?
Dafür liebe ich halt diese Demokratie, in der wir leben.
Eigentlich darfst du das halt. Du hast das Recht, wenn du sagst,
das ist eine Versammlung.
Ich mache eine Versammlung dort und mein Thema ist Demokratie.
Und dann hast du sogar das Recht, da was aufzubauen.
Und dann gibt es da Verhandlungsmasse. Die Bundespolizei sagt zu allem nein,
die ist dort zuständig für die Sicherheit.
Und die Versammlungsbehörde sagt zu allem eigentlich ja. Und dann gibt es so
Kompetenzschwierigkeiten, aber das führt am Ende dazu, die sagen dann,
die ist in der Baustelle, dann sagst du, ja, geh ich weiter nach da.
Irgendwann kriegst du halt, okay, du darfst es. Und dann wirst du noch genervt,
weil dann haben wir dort aufgebaut.
Das war interessant, dann kamen wir mit einem Stromerzeuger an.
Und die hatten uns alles aufbauen lassen. Es stand alles, wirklich ein Riesengerüst,
5 x 8 Meter und so weiter. Dann laden wir von einem Laster einen Stromerzeuger ab.
Und dann sagen wir zu den Bundespolizeidoktoren, könnt ihr mal eure Poller runterfahren,
damit wir den Stromerzeuger hier durchfahren können.
Und dann sagen die, ja, okay, ich funke mal durch an die Leitstelle. Nach drei Sekunden, nö.
Außerdem muss der direkt wieder weg. Ihr habt hier keinen Stromerzeuger angemeldet.
Klar haben wir einen Stromerzeuger angemeldet. Also wieder die Versammlungsbehörde
angerufen, die lassen uns unseren Stromerzeuger nicht.
Dann guckt der Typ in der Versammlungsbehörde rein, da steht aber doch ein Stromerzeuger drin.
Dann sagt er, ja, was sagen sie denn doch? Ja, nee, ich sag denen dann,
die hören nicht auf mich, die sagen einfach nur nein die ganze Zeit.
Okay, ich rufe da jetzt an.
Dann ruft er dann wieder bei der Bundespolizei an und dann ruft er mich zurück und sagt,
Ja, Stromerzeuger dürft ihr haben, aber die fahren die Poller dafür nicht runter,
weil sie sagen, die können natürlich Stromerzeuger haben, aber wir fahren einfach
diese Pollern nicht runter.
Und dann mussten wir den Stromerzeuger, das ist so, ihr könnt euch das so vorstellen,
der ist ein Meter sechzig ungefähr mal ein Meter und steht auf einer Palette
und um den gut zu fahren, musst du so mit dem Hubwagen in die Palette und dann so quer den nehmen.
Und dann passt er aber nicht zwischen den Pollern durch. Und die Polizisten
sehen das und sagen, ja ihr könnt das hier durchfahren.
Die haben die Fernbedienung in der Hand für ihren scheiß verfickten Poller.
Und gucken dir dann dabei zu, wie du auf einmal in einem zweiten Hubwagen,
zweite Palette, ein bisschen hoch, ein bisschen Ding, bist du irgendwann von
zwei Seiten mit zwei Dingern, da steht dieser so dumm daneben und gucken.
Ja, natürlich darfst du das hier. Und dann, ich hab gedacht,
was für, also tut mir leid, ich weiß nicht, ob man hier Wichser sagen kann, aber.
Also darfst du denen, kannst du halt nicht sagen.
Nee, nicht vor Ort, aber ich mein, wie kann man so ein Arschloch sein,
dass man sagt, ja, du darfst hier, natürlich darfst du hier das haben,
aber ich musste ja nicht irgendwie noch das Ding.
Dann standen die da mit ihrem Runterlassding und haben sich das genüsslich angeguckt
und dann war der Stromerzeuger da.
Zurück zur Kernfrage. Darf man einfach in Deutschland sowas dahin stellen?
Also du darfst es auch und jeder Hörer darf das auch.
Also ihr habt das als Veranstaltung begrenzten Zeitraum?
Dauer, genau.
Dauerwarnwache.
Für vier Tage, vier Nächte.
Dann geht halt nachts irgendwann die Versammlungsleitung auf den Security über
oder so, aber du musst halt immer da sein. Wenn du weg bist,
ist die Versammlung vorbei.
Das ist so die rechtliche… Also eine Person muss da mindestens sein.
Wenn eine Person da ist, wenn keiner mehr da ist… Aber eine Person kannst du
da nicht hinstellen, weil die Angst haben muss, dass sie nachts einen auf die Nase kriegt.
Am Bundeskanzler muss du da nicht so viel Angst haben, sag ich jetzt mal.
Also am Kotti kriegst du es vielleicht nachts auf die Nase oder irgendwie in
der Weidlingstraße in Lichtenberg.
Ja, ich hätte, sind da auch mal so irgendwie, gab's da Unmutsbekundungen?
Gab, ja natürlich gab Leute, ja gab, gab Leute, die kamen vorbei.
Also die allermeisten Leute fanden es spannend und haben sich's angeguckt und fanden es gut.
Und dann gab's natürlich die üblichen Verdächtigen, die üblichen Nazis,
die kommen dann vorbei, sozusagen.
Und machen Fotos.
Machen Fotos und trollen halt.
Aber an sich ist das kein guter Ort für die, von den AfDlern,
das war ja Sitzungswoche, kam jetzt keiner vorbei.
So, jetzt sollen wir mal ein bisschen vorankommen hier mit dem,
was ich eigentlich erzählen will.
Genau, Punkt ist, Website ist da, alles ist da und für uns geht es hier wirklich
viel auch um diese, für uns, wenn man das Zentrum kennt, dann geht es oft darum,
Wir machen irgendwas Spektakuläres,
wo alle sagen, oh krass,
um dann eine Message zu bringen und Inhalt zu bringen.
Also wir versuchen mit einem Presslufthammer irgendwas aufzuhämmern,
um dann da unseren Inhalt rein liefern zu können.
Und der Inhalt ist hier tatsächlich, deswegen empfehle ich allen wirklich nicht
bei dem Video zu verbleiben, sondern ein bisschen durch unser Archiv auf afdverbot.de,
zu gucken und sich einzulesen.
Denn, was bisher noch nicht richtig durchgekommen ist, weil wir diesen Deepfake produziert haben,
ist quasi der Inhalt. Also die Medien haben sich damit begnügt.
Von unserer Webseite, die glaube ich dreieinhalbtausend Unterseiten hat.
Nur die Startseite.
Die Startseite, mehr ist nicht. In medial zumindest, also in ganz wenigen Artikeln
von ein bisschen gründlichen Journalisten tönt das an.
Aber der Deepfake als solcher ist auf jeden Fall das, was alles quasi überlagert.
Und jetzt angeschlossen daran ein Copyright-Streit oder ein Zensurstreit eigentlich,
denn unser Olaf-Video wurde mittlerweile von der Bundesregierung at Gmail,
kommen,
sondern ich nenne die Bundesregierung jetzt leider nur noch Bundesregierung Social Media Punkt 1.
Was?
Die Bundesregierung Social Media Punkt 1 hat das?
Genau, bundesregierung.socialmedia.1.gmail.com,
hat,
sich,
bei,
Youtube,
gemeldet.
Aha.
Also die bundesregierung.socialmedia.1.gmail.com,
das,
ist,
die.
Behörde von Stefan Hewe, Streit dem Regierungsprecher, also der ist unser Antragsgegner,
also der hat sich bei Youtube gemeldet und hat gesagt, hallo hier spricht also
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland, bundesregierung social media, gmail.com.
Das Video enthält verletzt unsere Rechte, nämlich wir haben ein Recht an unserem
Flaggenstab, nämlich das schwarz-rot-gold mit dem Adler und der Bundeskanzler.
Einerseits, damit haben sie auf Instagram das Video, die Copyright-Geschichte,
gemacht und auf YouTube haben sie die Copyright-Geschichte gemacht mit,
unser Recht ist verletzt, denn das ist die Olaf-Scholz-Rede von dem und dem
Datum und wir sind der Urheber und das ganze Video muss runter,
weil wir sind der rechte Inhaber dieses Videos und es ist nicht bei uns lizenziert.
Und dann hat also quasi, das hat die Bundesregierung, socialmedia.1.gmail.com an,
YouTube,
geschrieben und daraufhin hat YouTube das Video tatsächlich gestern,
um
Uhr offline geschaltet.
Und wir haben gedacht, hä, was ist jetzt los? Und dann unsere Rechtsabteilung wiederum hat gesagt,
hä, hä, geht gar nicht, weil die Bundesregierung hat keine Rechte an einer Ansprache
an die Nation vom Bundeskanzler.
Daran gibt es kein Urheberrecht. Und das Logo der Bundeskanzlei,
also wenn du jetzt, Lock, Buch, Neck, habt ihr eine Wortbildmarke?
Lock, Buch, Neck, habt ihr eine Wortbildmarke?
Schwieriges Thema.
Nein?
Also wenn ihr eine hättet, dann würdet ihr euch davor schützen,
dass ich die auch benutze im gewerblichen Verkehr.
Aber nicht bei Kunst. Also das haben die Anwälte auch gesagt. Hä?
Also erstens, an dieser Rede haben sie keine Rechte und zweitens,
du kannst keinen Schutz gegen eine quasi Persiflage auf dein Logo von Künstlern
anwenden. Das geht nicht so.
So und drum haben wir jetzt eben die Bundesregierung abgemahnt und fordern Unterlassung.
Ja vor allem ein Urheberrecht liegt ja bei dem Urheber dieses Logos und mit
Sicherheit wird die Bundesregierung für diesen, wie haben das genannt Flaggenstab?
Wie heißt das? Das heißt Flaggenstab.
Ja für den Flaggenstab werden sie sicherlich jetzt nicht bei jeder Verwendung
mal den Urheber fragen, sondern die haben da ein uneingeschränktes Nutzungsrecht.
Nutzungsrecht und äh...
Ja interessant ist, dass der Anwalt, also unsere Anwalt sagt jetzt so,
die Bundesregierung behauptet, sie hätte ein uneingeschränktes Nutzungsrecht
auf all das, auf diese Rede und auf diesen Plankenstab.
Und unser Anwalt sagt, das habt ihr nicht und wir würden sie darin verletzen.
Und unser Anwalt sagt, ihr habt überhaupt keins dieser Rechte.
Und ihr verletzt uns hingegen unser Kunstwerk, worauf wir ein uneingeschränktes
Nutzungsrecht haben, auszuüben.
Und deswegen haben wir jetzt gefordert von der Bundesregierung mit Frist,
Dienstag 15 Uhr, dass sie unterschreibt, dass sie es unterlässt in Zukunft, strafbewehrt,
unwahre Behauptungen gegenüber YouTube und so weiter und Meta und so weiter
zu äußern, dass sie irgendwelche Rechte an etwas hätten, wofür wir Rechte hatten.
Das Zitat ist, das können meine Mandanten leider nicht dulden.
Und das heißt muss Steffen Hebe Streit bis Dienstag 15 Uhr unterschreiben,
sonst gehen wir vor Gericht.
Die Bundesregierung wurde jetzt in der Bundespressekonferenz konfrontiert.
Damit einmal sah ich, aber da muss man auch Thilo Jung, kommt bestimmt hier
der Link, hat das angebracht und gefragt, was für Rechte habt ihr da eigentlich,
was wollt ihr da eigentlich?
Und da kam nur, wir haben ein gesamtes Paket an Rechten und das haben wir hier geltend gemacht.
Und dann wurde gefragt, aber was genau für Rechte haben sie nicht beantwortet
und nicht beantworten können?
Was sie gesagt haben ist, sie weisen Zensur von sich, weil da wurde gefragt,
das ist ja eigentlich Zensur. Und das Urheberrecht ist eigentlich dafür da,
dass Kreativschaffende von ihrem Werk leben können, davon Geld verdienen können.
Es ist nicht dafür da, dass die Bundesregierung Künstlern verbieten kann,
ein Video zu verbreiten.
Und die haben gesagt, Zensur weisen sie von sich.
Sie haben nur gegenüber Meta, YouTube und so weiter darauf hingewiesen,
dass da ihre Rechte verletzt werden.
Und dann muss man sagen, was ist denn eigentlich Zensur? Wenn du gehst so hin
und sagst, ja hier ist die Bundesrepublik Deutschland,
ich bin das Land, ich bin die viertmächtigste Industrienation und sagst,
das Video da hätte ich gern offline.
Aus hier meine XY Gründung.
Und sie begründen es ja auch, die gute Frau in der Pressekonferenz begründet
es ja auch wirklich nicht mit irgendeinem Recht, sondern damit,
dass das Video falsch ist, sie sagt ja, wenn irgendwo Bundesregierung draufsteht,
muss auch Bundesregierung drin sein.
Und wenn es Kunst ist, muss da Kunst dranstehen. Also das ist das, was sie sagt.
Sie sagt tatsächlich, wenn da
sowas ist, dann muss da vorher groß Deepfake stehen, der Begriff Deepfake.
Aber das ist wirklich so, da gibt es eine lange Debatte dazu,
das ist nicht so, dass wenn irgendwas Kunst ist, dass man davor so ein Schild
nageln muss, Vorsicht Kunst.
Und dass es dann unzumutbar ist, dass der Bürger darf, es ist auch nicht so,
dass Kunst einen Bürger nicht verunsichert, weil die sagen, der Bürger ist verunsichert.
Ist es nicht so, dass Kunstfreiheit, Grundgesetz, da aufhört,
wo der Bürger verunsichert ist? Ob das jetzt wirklich Olaf Scholz ist?
Eine Zensur findet nicht statt.
Also meiner Meinung nach ist es eigentlich die Definition von Zensur,
wenn du zu einem Medienverbreitungskanal hingehst und sagst… Als Bundesregierung. Als Bundesregierung.
Als Staat.
Als Staat, genau. Und sagst, ja, bitte offline.
Das ist schon geil. Und wir haben ein ganzes Paket. Übrigens,
wir haben ein ganzes Paket, warum du es auf Land einsachst.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man nicht vielleicht eine Woche nach diesem Haushaltsurteil
vom Verfassungsgericht...
Vielleicht sich doppelt und dreifach mal überlegt, aber naja.
Also AfD und Bundesregierung haben einfach ihren Streisand nicht gelesen.
Ja genau.
Und ihr habt jetzt Unterlassung gefordert und das muss der Regierungssprecher unterschreiben?
Ja das fand ich besonders schön an der Unterlassungserklärung.
Das ist an den Persönlichen. Strafbewehrte Unterlassungserklärung.
Hiermit verpflichtet sich die Bundesrepublik Deutschland, vertreten durch das
Presse- und Informationsamt der Bundesregierung, dieses wiederum vertreten durch
Pressesprecher Steffen Hebestreit.
Erstens ist zu unterlassen auf den Plattformen Instagram, YouTube das Video
von Artists for Democracy.
Endlich, Bundesregierung verbietet die AfD zu melden und dabei mitzuteilen,
das Video verletzte die Urheber- und Markenrechte des Bundes,
wie geschehen im Falle von diesem Video.
Und zweitens bei zuwiderhandlung jeweils eine strafe zu zahlen mindestens 5.500 Euro.
Genau und das muss sie unterschreiben, das muss Steffen Hebestreit unterschreiben.
War der das denn persönlich?
Nee, aber er steht im Amt vor. Und wir haben das jetzt geschickt an... Warte... an bundes...
Bundesregierung.socialmedia.de.
Wir haben es auch noch an eine zweite Adresse geschickt. Es gibt nämlich zwei
E-Mail-Adressen. Falls jemand
mal sich bei der Bundesregierung über Social Media-Sachen aufregen will.
Also, dann ist der eine ist bundespresseamt.socialmedia.1.at,
googlemail.com.
Und das zweite ist, wo wir es hingeschrieben haben, internetpost.bundesregierung.de.
Internetpost.
Das sind die offiziellen E-Mail-Adressen der Bundesregierung.
Internetpost. Gibt's auch eine andere Post da, die man in die Bundesregierung hinschicken kann?
Faxpost at 030, keine Ahnung. Internetpost.
Oh man ey.
Ja genau. So ist der Stand. Das ist der aktuelle Stand der Geschichte.
Was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist, dass es schade ist, dass es in so einem Zensurstreit entartet.
Entartet? Es entartet in einem Zensurstreit.
Und deswegen nochmal wirklich an die Hörer.
Checkt mal und filtert euch mal schön durch diese Fälle durch.
Und jetzt will ich noch einen Punkt sagen, was für mich immer so ein Hintergrund der Aktion ist.
Wir haben hier natürlich diese Kanzler-Deepfake-Geschichte,
aber,
unser Stunt quasi zu sagen, wir produzieren hier den Scholz,
hat vor allem auch dafür gesorgt, dass quasi alle großen Medienhäuser uns verlinken.
Also der Link, afd-verbot.de,
der.
Ist überall, überall, überall gepostet,
worden,
und hat jetzt deswegen sehr hohe Relevanz mit dem Themenbereich AfD.
Jetzt stellt euch mal vor, ihr seid der Googlebot und der Bot von irgendeiner
Suchmaschine, der guckt, oh, Thema AfD, wer hat hier Relevanz?
Dann gucke ich mal, oh der hat Spiegel-Verlinkung, Dies-Verlinkung,
überall Verlinkung und zwar noch in diesem Themenbereich AfD sogar,
also themenrelevante Links ist, was SEO am wichtigsten ist. Dann liegt auf unserer Seite robots.txt,
die listet alle Unterprofile auf, nämlich die Namen der Leute,
die wir beschuldigen und deren Einzelseiten.
Das heißt jetzt, es wird nicht lange dauern, dann sind wir mit allen diesen
Namen der AfD-Funktionäre bei Google jeweils ganz oben, größtenteils über der
AfD und über ihrer eigenen Homepage.
Das heißt jetzt, das ist die lange Sicht, was hat das für einen Effekt,
wenn schon unsere Politik das nicht schafft, hier ein Verbot aufzugleisen?
Immerhin wird es so sein, dass wenn du, wie heißt da hier unsere Karte? Wo ist sie denn?
Die ganz gelbe.
Ne, wir hatten doch gerade eine Quartett-Karte.
Ja, aber ich sag dir den ganz demokratiefeindlichen.
Ja, aber ich nehm den.
Bernd Baumann.
Ja, nehm einfach den. Angenommen jetzt, es dauert vielleicht noch ne Woche oder
so, aber dann geb ich Brief und Siegel.
Wer Bernd Baumann sucht, der wird als oberstes Resultat bei Google AfD-Verbot.de,
Bernd,
Baumann angezeigt bekommen.
Was sagt der mir jetzt?
Eure Robots.txt müsst ihr mal fixen.
Ah ja, ok.
User Agent All. Aber da müsst ihr nochmal...
Ne, ist nichts verboten. Ist auch nicht explizit genannt.
Achso, aber die enthält aber quasi... Ah ne, das ist eine andere.
Das ist nicht die Robots.txt, sondern das ist eine andere Datei.
Es gibt eine Sitemap. Genau.
Solche Fehler kannst du bei uns nicht machen.
Scheiße. Ich sag noch URL und Tim und so Curl, Disillusion, green letter.
Na, jetzt haben wir's, oder?
Da sollten immer ein paar mehr Einträge als nur das drin sein, oder?
Ja, ja, das geht noch ein bisschen weiter.
Das geht aber hoffentlich ordentlich weiter. Ja, das ist SidemapXML, das ist auf jeden Fall.
Das, SidemapXML, der größte Antifaschist Deutschlands.
Genau, also da, so ist das gedacht.
So, wie geht es jetzt weiter? Wie geht es jetzt weiter? Das kann ich noch nicht
sagen, das ist so ein bisschen Überraschungskram.
Aber eigentlich wolltet ihr… Warte mal, also ein paar Fragen.
Also, der Impact, ihr habt das ja, das macht ihr ja eigentlich immer,
das finde ich auch wirklich bemerkenswert.
Ihr denkt das alles akribisch und ihr beachtet eben auch viele Aspekte,
rechtliche Aspekte, also ihr begebt euch da auf Terrain, von dem ihr zumindest
vorher schon gecheckt habt,
was da sozusagen potenziell für Fallen drohen, weil es natürlich klar ist.
Die kommen natürlich dann alle angerannt und sagen erstmal verboten,
verboten, verboten seid ihr.
Und das finde ich auch immer so
geil, dass dann einfach, es wird sich dann einfach irgendwas ausgedacht.
Ja, Urheberrecht hier und irgendwie keine Ahnung, also irgendwas wird einfach
geschrieben von irgendwelchen Anwälten, was keine Hand und keinen Fuß hat.
Und gut, so, jetzt habt ihr ein Echo erzeugt, definitiv, ihr habt es ja schon
gesagt, alle haben sich jetzt erstmal auf dieses Scholz-Video konzentriert.
Wir haben das ja jetzt auch am Anfang eingespielt, dass alle das mal gehört
haben. Klar, also es ist sehr seine Stimme.
Klar, wenn man das Video anguckt, geht es ein bisschen besser, aber passt schon.
Da reden jetzt alle drüber. Seid ihr damit glücklich, dass das jetzt erstmal
das ist, wo sich alle drauf konzentrieren und dass diese umfangreiche Datensammlung,
die jetzt da auch ist, so gar nicht vorkommt erstmal in der Wiedergabe?
Im Gegenteil. Ich hätte das gar nicht gedacht, dass Leute da so drauf abfahren,
auf diesen Deepfake-Moment.
Das ist was, was natürlich alle sagen, damit kann man sich an der Sache nicht
mehr sicher sein, aber da frage ich zurück.
Als ihr vor 15 Jahren Herr der Ringe im Kino geguckt habt, habt ihr euch da
eigentlich nicht gewundert, dass Gandalf deutsch spricht?
Ja, also genau das meine ich.
Deepfake, das wird so herbeigeredet, ich sag da gleich in Tiefe gerne,
aber die Tools, die da sind und so weiter und so fort,
Qualitativ ist, wenn du ein hochwertiges Dubbing machst, also so heißt es,
das heißt Film, übrigens die Filmindustrie ist auch die, die das Deepfaken gerade voranbringt.
Also du meinst jetzt nicht, dass er Deutsch spricht, sondern dass er auch die
Mundbewegungen dazu macht?
Naja, das ist so ein Gandalf im Herr der Ringe, du hast ja immer den im Kino,
der wird früher angeguckt und dann kann der auf einmal, eigentlich der Film
wurde, der Schauspieler hat mal Englisch gesprochen,
aber jetzt spricht er hier Deutsch. Und das ist drauf gedubbt.
Und da guckt man, dass der Dubbing-Sprecher so ein bisschen ungefähr den Wortfluss,
also man guckt halt, dass das passt.
Das ist mega aufwendig und auch teuer, aber es bringt ein besseres Ergebnis
als unser Deepfake auf jeden Fall, als unser technisch generiertes Lippenmodell.
Und was halt die Stimme ist, was die Stimme angeht. Ja, Olaf Scholz ist jetzt
wirklich so eine langweilige Stimme, dass es da halt keinen richtigen...
Habt ihr schon mal so einen Olaf Scholz-Imitator gehört irgendwo?
Das gibt's nicht, aber... Ich hab's nicht gehört! Ich auch nicht.
Könnt ihr euch nicht an Helmut Kohl erinnern? Jeder, erstens so,
in meinem Freundeskreis konnte fast jeder so einen halbwegs faszinierenden Helmut Kohl machen.
Ich bin dick gefällt und hab ein Doppelkinn, weil ich der Kanzler bin.
Also, das war der Olaf Scholz.
Auch der Schröder. Im Radio gab's immer so, hey, der Imitator von Jungs und Nichts.
Gib mir mal ne Flasche Bier.
So, das gab's früher.
Aber Scholz ist einfach nur die festgefressene Langeweile. Das ist wirklich unglaublich.
Keiner will den imitieren. Oder der eine, wenn man versucht,
den zu imitieren, schläft man ein dabei.
Der kommt eh schon so computergeneriert rüber. Das ist wirklich krass.
Wobei genau das dann wieder schwieriger ist zu generieren, wenn jemand so… Der
hat ja schon irgendwas, was du nachmachen kannst, aber es ist wirklich nur der Klang der Stimme.
Es gibt irgendwie im Radio irgendwie so Regierungs-WG oder so und da hab ich
mich immer gefragt, wer soll das sein?
Ja, bis ich dann irgendwann so gedacht hab, naja, also wenn da irgendwie,
also, da wird dann wohl der Kanzler sein.
Aber da gibt's jemanden, den kannst du ja auch nicht so wirklich nachmachen, ne?
Ja, nee, also zumindest google mal. Es gab schon dieses Modeln.
Ich hab dann so gegoogelt, weil wir dachten auch so, oh scheiße,
das ist total schwierig, das D-Pack zu machen, sieht nicht gut aus und so.
Aber wir haben auch schon geguckt, ja wer hat denn so, wer kann einem...
Weil wir waren auf der Suche, ich war zwischenzeitlich auf der Suche.
Nach einem Olaf-Scholz-Imitator,
und,
wollte,
eigentlich am liebsten Dubbing machen. Also das war ein Zwischenschritt,
weil man sagte, das bringt am Schluss ein besseres Ergebnis.
Also jemand, der wirklich gut die Stimme nachmacht und dann dubbst du das einfach
auf irgendwas anderes, was er geredet hat, drauf.
Und das macht die Filmindustrie seit Jahrzehnten und das ist dann eigentlich,
deswegen habe ich das gerade mit Gandalf gesagt, das ist ein Deepfake,
kannst du dann sagen. Ein Stimmimitator und drauf.
Und jetzt das Neue ist, dass man sowas computeranimieren kann.
Das Ergebnis ist aber nicht besser. Und jetzt tut man so, als sei der Deepfake irgendwas aus 2023,
dabei ist der eigentlich was aus den 90er Jahren. Und diese Definition, die ist halt was Neues.
Aber es ist natürlich ein mediales Thema. Ihr seid sozusagen jetzt mitten in
diesen ganzen AI-Hype reingekratscht und da passt das natürlich perfekt.
Aber das ist ja nicht mit AI gemacht worden.
Was ist denn AI eigentlich?
Machine Learning.
Achso, ja.
Und damit habt ihr es denn gemacht?
Na mit irgendwelchen, also erstmal, eine Sache wollte ich vorhin noch sagen,
also an diese ganze AI, Machine Learning Geschichte und an Deepfake Videos,
da werden wir uns alle in zwei Jahren dran gewöhnt haben.
An die AfD im Bundestag werde ich mich nicht gewöhnt haben in zwei Jahren.
So, wir haben es gemacht mit, also es gibt verschiedene Techniken,
erstmal gibt es… Sorry, du musst doch die Frage beantworten, ich hab's auch gemerkt.
Ich wollte sagen, warum wir es gemacht haben, du hast doch gerade… Nee,
nee, nee, die Frage davor war die Aufmerksamkeit.
Ich hab's gerade bereut, dass ich die Frage jetzt nochmal nachgeschoben habe.
Lass uns vielleicht erst nochmal kurz bei diesem medialen Impact bleiben.
Also, die Leute fokussieren sich sozusagen da drauf, du bist da ganz glücklich mit.
Nee, ich bin da nicht glücklich mit.
Du bist da nicht glücklich mit. Okay, das meinte ich doch.
Ich dachte nämlich, das ist zu viel. Also wir hätten nicht mit so einem Fallout
gemeint, also gerechnet das, und das muss man so in der, wie sagt man, der Manöverkritik.
Erstens haben wir, wenn du selber so ein Video produzierst, siehst du natürlich
viel stärker, wie schlecht es ist.
Als wenn du jemandem sowas… Ich war irgendwann und dachte, das ist voll scheiße, das Video.
Und hab's dann irgendwelchen Freunden von mir kurz gezeigt und ich so,
krass, wann hat der das gesagt?
Ich so, hä?
Aber selber denkt man, weil man immer drauf guckt, ist scheiße,
scheiße, scheiße. Sonst wird aber in Wirklichkeit immer besser.
So, was war die Frage nochmal? Genau, der Impact.
Ich hätte nicht mir träumen lassen, dass sich das auch medial,
Medienkritik ist ja nicht sehr beliebt,
aber ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass man es wirklich schafft, an genau dieser
ersten Stelle so aufzubauschen und wirklich es nicht zu schaffen,
auch mal auf Seite 2 vom Buch auch zu lesen und so zu kontextualisieren und
dann das Ganze auch in so einen Kontext der Kunst zu stellen.
Denn wir sind ja eine Kunstgruppe sozusagen und wenn es jetzt neue Techniken
gibt, mit der man die Kunst macht, dann sollte man die oder jeder würde die dann auch nutzen.
Du wirst nicht sagen, das ist ja nicht so wie quasi selbsttötende,
selbst Kriegsentscheidung treffende Roboter-Drohnen, die irgendjemanden umbringen,
sondern du machst trotzdem ein Werk.
Du hast quasi neue Farben, die sind viel strahlender, mit denen du dein Gemälde malst.
Aber die benutzen wir nicht, weil dann sieht das Gemälde zu echt aus.
So, das ist also mal die Passivlage.
Und ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es medial so eine Verleihung,
weil es halt in so eine Fake-News-Ecke gestellt wird.
Fake-News ist aber, wenn irgendeinem Politiker irgendwas auf so einem kurzen
Twitter-Ding oder kurzes Video in den Mund gelegt wird, was er nie gesagt hat,
was so aussieht wie ein Leak oder sowas.
Oh und dann ist die Katastrophe groß und da.
Aber auf einer Webseite mit einem Impressum, wo wir genannt sind,
mit allem am Start, mit komischen Sachen, mit einem Crowdfunding,
wo es witzige Sachen von der Bundesregierung gibt, wo klar ist, das ist ein Kunstwerk.
Also ich sag's mal so, 80 Prozent der Leute, die auf diese Seite gehen,
sagen, ah, das Zentrum, geil.
Jetzt haben sie wieder einen losgerissen oder sagen wir 40 und dann nochmal
40 müssen sich einlesen, aber haben diese Kompetenz, um zu sagen,
hey, krass, das hat er nie gesagt.
Und jetzt zu sagen, aber diese 20%, die das nicht checken auf den ersten Blick
und dann sagen, dass deswegen jetzt Kunst Rücksicht auf die nehmen muss,
die das Werk nicht verstehen.
Also es ist wirklich dieses Vorsicht Kunst Ding.
Und das finde ich, dass das medial noch gepusht wird, an Diebfakes muss jetzt
so ein Zettel stehen, weil das werden ja sowieso nur die Leute machen, die es gut meinen.
Also wenn du jetzt als Bundesregierungspräsident sagst, da muss jetzt immer
Diebfake stehen, dann würden wir als Gruppe dann sagen, Diebfake.
Aber derjenige, der richtig böse Absichten hat, das ist doch genau das Video,
wo dann nicht Diebfake dran steht. Und dann denkt der Bürger,
ja, das war kein Diebfick, weil sonst hätte ja Diebfick dran gestanden.
Das ist doch das, was halt gefordert wird.
Ja, ja, klar. Aber ich meine, deine Prozentzahlen, die du gerade so mal ausgedacht
hast, würde ich ja ein bisschen bezweifeln.
Also ich glaube, dass wirklich viel mehr Leute da einfach, wenn sie da casual draufstoßen.
Sagen, ukros Disholz.
Ja, erstmal überhaupt gar nicht Kunst unbedingt erwarten, sondern eigentlich
immer, das spricht ja auch eigentlich für die Menschen.
Wir erwarten eigentlich immer, dass wir nicht belogen werden,
wir erwarten eigentlich immer, dass wir die Wahrheit sehen und dass irgendwie alles stimmt.
Und das wird eigentlich die ganze Zeit ausgenutzt. Das wird von den Leuten ausgenutzt,
die halt die echten Deepfakes machen, die halt einfach ein paar Lügen servieren.
So aber wenn dann die Künstler kommen und gepflegte Lügen servieren,
sehen sie es halt auch erstmal nicht so, selbst wenn es aus unserer Perspektive
offensichtlich erscheint.
Aber das Video enthält ja nun quasi eine Story, wenn man das Video anguckt,
es gibt ja eine Story in dem Video.
Und manipuliert ist ja nur der Scholz und seine Stimme und der Rest vom Video
ist straight up echtes Material.
AfDler, die Chemnitz-Geschichte, Walter Lübcke und die Message,
wir müssen jetzt was tun.
Und das sagt jetzt irgendjemand, in dem Fall der Bundeskanzler.
Aber von der Sache her ist ja nicht so, dass die Leute quasi in dem Video belogen
werden, Außer sie werden darüber hinweg getäuscht, wenn sie denn drauf reinfallen,
was wirklich glaube ich nicht so viele tun, hat der Bundeskanzler das jetzt
gesagt oder irgendjemand anders.
Macht es denn einen Unterschied, ob Tim Pridloff das sagt oder...
Ja gut, aber da muss ich dir jetzt kurz einhaken. Ja macht es,
weil du gerade selber gesagt hast, ein AfD-Verbotsverfahren kann nur anrollen,
die Bundesregierung, der Bundesrat oder der Bundestag.
Also da macht es dann schon einen Unterschied. Ich glaube...
Also ich verstehe schon, dass die sehr unwirisch und unsouverän darauf reagieren,
weil die natürlich auch seit längerer Zeit genau davor Schiss haben.
Und die Nachricht hier, jetzt soll die AfD verboten werden, wenn die von bestimmten
Leuten ernst genommen wird,
ist die natürlich geeignet, auch der AfD Auftrieb zu verleihen oder irgendwelche
Reichsbürger wieder auf die Idee zu bringen,
Knarren zu horten oder ihre gehorteten Knarren aus dem Keller zu holen. Also das ist schon eine,
also überhaupt, Parteiverbotsverfahren sind halt schon ein ziemlich,
ein heikles Thema in beide Richtungen, ja.
Wir haben ja auch Parteiverbote in Deutschland gehabt, jetzt beispielsweise KPD,
das war dann auch alles nicht so geeignet, dass dann alle sagen,
Also egal was da passiert, wenn jetzt irgendwie eine Partei verboten wird,
gibt es auf jeden Fall einen signifikanten Teil Leute, die sagen,
das geht mir jetzt zu weit oder ey das ist meine Partei und sagen wir mal, dass jetzt,
also dass das viele Leute erstmal als eine sehr böse und demokratie,
potenziell demokratiegefährdende Aktion sehen,
muss man, kann ich zumindest verstehen.
Ja ich nicht.
Ich seh's auch aus der Wahrheit. Wir haben doch mal gesagt, Deutschland entscheidet,
welche Flüchtlinge müssen sterben und welche dürfen kommen. Da gab's mal eine Votingseite von uns.
Da gab's dann die Joachim 1. Flüchtlinge fressen. Genau. Da gab's einen Flieger, der hieß Joachim 1.
Das war damals Joachim Gock, der Bundespräsident. Das war Bundesrepublik Deutschland.
Video war Bundesrepublik Deutschland.
Wie gesagt, auch da, also wenn, also ich muss wirklich nochmal da,
Vorsicht Kunst, also wann, wann darf, wo ist die Grenze zur Wirklichkeit,
weil unser Deepfake war, den fanden wir selber so scheiße, stellenweise.
Dass ihr euch geschämt habt dafür? Nee, dass wir überlegt haben,
den Olaf rauszunehmen, weil das mit dem Lip-Sync nicht wollte, so wie wir es wollten.
Und das Einzige, was an Deepfake-Technik funktioniert,
ist eigentlich diese Stimmgeschichte. Also das ist was, was tatsächlich neu
ist. Also oder zumindest auf dem End-User-Markt neu,
ist diese Stimmgeschichte, dass es möglich ist Stimmen zu synthetisieren.
Vielleicht kannst du ja mal ein Beispiel uns einspielen.
Mach ich doch.
Aber vielleicht mal kurz, mich interessiert das mit dieser Aufmerksamkeit und
was ihr sozusagen als Erfolg wertet.
Also hat euch das jetzt quasi, also hast du das Gefühl, das hat euch jetzt schon
ein bisschen den Wind aus den Segeln genommen diese Wahrnehmung?
Hättest du lieber ein neutrales Video gehabt, wo einfach irgendwie ein Verbot gefordert wird?
Nee, denn der Skandal ist ja Teil der Inszenierung. Also man muss sagen,
wir waren enttäuscht darüber, dass quasi das Medial teilweise,
also der Tiefgang nicht erreicht wurde.
Also quasi dahinter zu gucken und den Leuten nicht genug zugemutet wurde.
Es gab ja oftmals auch diese Berichte, es gab es bei RTL glaube ich,
Achtung dieses Video ein Deepfake, so konnte das Team von unseren Deepfake Experten
das entlarven und sowas.
Was, das konnten sie entlarven? Wirklich? Ja, doch. Ich hatte Elvis gemerkt.
Kein Wort dahinter, was ist dahinter. Aber das ist ein Anspruch und Wirklichkeit,
da verstehe ich nicht gleich.
Ja, natürlich, man würde sie jetzt auch hinsetzen und sagen,
heul doch, du hast hier so eine Kuh durchs Dorf getrieben.
Und ärgerst dich, dass alle über die Kuh reden, sozusagen, ne?
Also es ist schon so, natürlich sichert das Aufmerksamkeit dem Thema und ich
bin mir auch sicher, dass es noch genug ist.
Es ist ja noch nicht vorbei, denn erstmals, wir haben ja immer so einen,
da steigt die Rakete, dann gibt es ein kurzes Feuerwerk und dann stürzt sie
auch eigentlich komplett ab.
Und nach zehn Tagen sitzen alle da, boah, war das anstrengend und machen gar
nichts mehr erst mal, wenn sie ausruhen.
Und diesmal ist es ein Dauerlauf, denn diese Website ist gekommen,
um zu bleiben so und das heißt, wenn ich es aus der Warte sehe,
ich will Aufmerksamkeit auf dieser Website haben,
dann, wir haben ja nicht, das ist ja die Stärke vom Z-Pass, mit relativ wenig
Geld, jetzt auch nicht mehr mit so wenig Geld wie früher, aber mit trotzdem noch,
du kannst auf jeden Fall keine Werbekampagne, wenn du sagst,
ich hab eine neue Website.
Timbritloveseinhornshirts.de Oder du hast natürlich ein anderes Mittel,
ich brauche eine andere.
Irgendjemand hat eine neue Website und sagt, die will ich jetzt launchen und
ich will möglichst viel Power drauf. Ich will, dass die bekannt wird.
Dann, wie viel Geld braucht man denn, damit ein Viertel der Deutschen die kennt?
Millionen!
Genau. Und wir kommen mit viel,
viel weniger, aber wir haben ja wirklich gigantisch viel weniger Augen.
Das stimmt.
So, um zu sagen, wir haben eine neue Webseite, jetzt machen wir halt den ultimativen Skandal,
bumm und dann reden alle drüber und dann hat man die Reichweite sozusagen und
dann ist die Webseite ja da, die ist in dem Fall ja nicht weg dann,
die bleibt sozusagen und von daher ich,
man hätte immer sich ein bisschen besser was anderes gewünscht sozusagen,
aber ich bin auch nicht der Söder, der beim ZDF anruft und sagt, das passt mir nicht.
In die laufende Sendung, oder? Hat er das nicht gemacht? Ich glaub schon.
Oder? Söder hat doch mal mit dem ZDF angerufen. Ich glaub in der laufenden Sendung
hat Söder mal angerufen und gesagt, das gefällt ihm nicht hier.
Also drum, wir nehmen es wie es ist.
Aber die Bundesregierung ruft bei Youtube an.
Ja genau, weil die Bundesregierung hat Gmail bekommen.
Okay, also der Skandal, ja das stimmt. Es geht bloß ein bisschen noch weiter,
als du damit gerechnet hast.
Ja genau so.
Okay, aber lass uns mal kurz dann doch über die Technik mal reden,
die er da jetzt zum Laufen gebracht hat. Das wird dir sicherlich eine Menge interessieren.
Also das Video, das Original-Video von dem Scholz, was ihr genommen habt,
das war jetzt was? Was war das, die Silvesteransprache?
Nee, das war die Ansprache, die Silvesteransprache ist lame, da sitzt er.
Ich hab mir das nicht angesehen, deswegen weiß ich es nicht.
Es ist nicht so, dass du bei Scholz aus so einem riesigen Repertoire von geilen Reden...
Dann nehmen wir die, die gute Szene gesetzt.
Oh, die und die ist aber eng, aber nee, nee.
Klassiker.
Dass du fürchterliche Reden hast und ganz schlimme. Und die beste ist immer
noch tatsächlich für so einen Fall, das war die Ansprache auf allen Sendern
glaube ich sogar oder auf vielen Sendern zum Überfall auf die Ukraine.
Da hat er eine Fernsehansprache gemacht und das ist eine, die interessanterweise
dann wiederum produziert in relativ niedriger Auflösung, also das ist vom Hauptstadtstudio
produziert worden in 1080p.
Man hätte gedacht, 22 der Regierungsstelle, ich zumindest hätte gedacht,
das wird mit der maximalen Technik, die es gibt, aber die ist relativ niedrig aufgelöst.
So und das ist die, weil er da wirklich redet, lange vor einem Ding und man
hat viele Stellen, um sich was anzutrainieren.
Denn die Technik ist eigentlich so, es gibt zwei Techniken, die völlig nichts
miteinander zu tun haben oder wenig.
Synthetisierung der Stimme ist das eine Thema und das andere ist dann Lip-Syncing,
auf ein Video sozusagen.
Und Synthesisierung der Stimme ist nicht einfach, aber einfacher als das Lip-Syncing.
Viel einfacher. Weil da gibt es Online-Tools für uns,
einfacher, ich glaube aber auch für alle einfacher.
Das ist einfach, bei einer Stimme… Das ist ja auch so eine Technik her,
das ist ja etwas, was auch erst in den letzten Jahren richtig gereift ist.
Genau, aber die andere Sache, das Lip-Syncing, ist ja nicht gereift.
Also beziehungsweise ist es gereift.
Als Lipsyncing ist das jetzt sozusagen, dass du das Audio so anpasst,
dass es zum Video passt oder dass du das Video so anpasst, dass es zum Audio passt?
Also dass du ein Videoschnipsel von jemandem nimmst und dann soll das umgerechnet
werden, so dass dein Mund zum neuen Audio passt.
Das ist das Lipsyncing. Das ist nicht ausgereift, was man auch am Video absolut sieht.
Und dann gibt es das Audio-Ding. Und das Audio-Ding ist eher so,
das bezieht sich eher auf Frequenzen, Höhen und so weiter.
Auch dass es nicht ausgreift, aber da kannst du was mitmachen.
Kann ich mal was einspielen?
Ja, kannst du.
Das ist schon noch lustig, ne?
Ja, das ist lustig.
Ja genau.
Das ist nämlich auch einfach eine lustige Geschichte.
Der Olaf, der hat ganz schön Scheik im Nacken. Ja, ja, ja, ein Tripp,
der haut einen Gassenhauer nach dem anderen raus.
Du hattest Gauland, hattest du auch noch, ne?
Ich hab Gauland, ja, ich kann Stimmen machen und das Tool,
was wir am Ende genutzt haben, ohne Werbung machen zu wollen,
macht man eigentlich, sagt man, ist doch hier transparent, wir haben 11 Labs viel genutzt.
Ist eigentlich auch wieder so eine Cloud-Lösung, ist eine der wenigen,
die überhaupt mit Deutsch halbwegs zurechtkommen, muss man sagen.
Jetzt haben wir noch hier...
Genau, ist eine der wenigen, die überhaupt richtig damit klarkommen, mit Deutsch.
Und da ist es aber auch wieder so, es ist nicht so, es ist wirklich nicht so,
also man darf es sich jetzt nicht vorstellen, wir dachten, es ist so am Anfang
und jetzt kann ich euch sagen, es ist nicht so.
Wir dachten am Anfang, geil, wir schreiben eine geile Rede für den Scholz.
Das ist ja einfach, schreib eine geile Rede für den Scholz. Also im Vergleich
zu allem anderen, sagst du, machst ein Pad auf, ein paar Leute,
trinkst ein paar Bier und machst eine richtig gute Rede für den Scholz sozusagen.
Und dann denkst du, gut, copy-paste in das Tool, jetzt machen wir eine Rede draus.
Dann hört sich das so brutal endscheiße an. Also die Tools funktionieren alle
so, du nimmst einen Audio-Fetzen, eine Stimme und gibst die ihm als Training.
Und dann kannst du teilweise sagen, Ich gebe ihm verschiedene Audio-Fetzen als Training,
aber da musst du aufpassen, weil wenn du dann, dann dachten wir,
okay cool, wir nehmen einen Scholz, wie er so eine schöne Rede macht und einen,
wo er ruhig ist, aber das Tool errechnet einen Mittelwert aus all diesen Stimmen
und dann hast du auf einmal so einen, das ist dann gar nicht mehr Scholz, oder?
Aber der Scholz klingt unterschiedlich auf verschiedenen Aufnahmen,
den anderen hatte ich ja noch nie.
Doch, der hat eine Bundestagsrede, kann ich nur empfehlen, wo er so sagt,
sie sind hier ausgestiegen und da ausgestiegen, aber sie säten nie den Mut in
irgendeine Technik ein.
Er hat so eine wütende, auch einmal hat er sich ausgerastet als so ein Pfeifleute bei seinem Wahlkampf.
Und da dachte man natürlich, okay, ich rechne alles rauschen raus,
weil da ist er mein Scholz. Aber am Ende wird das scheiße, das ist zu kurz,
das ist nicht konsistent.
Dann haben wir ihn genommen, unter anderem, also wie du ihn dann füttern musst,
um ein vernünftiges Ergebnis zu kriegen ist, du nimmst eigentlich ein langes Ding von ihm.
Wir haben dann Zeit-Online-Talks oder,
sowas, weil da ist so, Zeit-Online, es gibt so ein Zeitgespräch mit Olaf Scholz,
und da ist so, die sind so total unterwürfig und stellen ihm so eine Frage und,
dann antwortet er siebeneinhalb Minuten.
Und keiner traut sich zu klatschen, das ist total wie bei einer Beerdigung,
aber … Das wäre doch vielleicht auch, wenn er nicht mehr Kanzler ist,
das wäre doch ein Job für ihn, oder?
Ja, also Beerdigungsredner. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein extrem guter, also für diese Stimme.
Und vor allem mit dem, ich bin der Ex-Kanzler, jetzt kannst du mich für deine
Beerdigung mieten oder also für die, das ist auf jeden Fall,
da kann man… Ja ich meine als Kanzler hat er sich jetzt nicht so qualifiziert,
aber da könnte er dann durchaus auch nochmal Karriere machen.
Wenn du so eine richtige auf die Urkuck Beerdigung haben willst, dann kannst du den.
Du nimmst also quasi so eine lange von ihm, weil du so einen leichten Nuancen
in der Stimme brauchst, sonst machst du alles mit dem selben Stimmding.
Das heißt, du nimmst also aus seinen ersten sieben Minuten Antwort,
wählst du da hoch, als eine Stimme.
Du machst nicht aus allen wieder eins, sondern du machst einfach eine Stimme
aus den ersten sieben Minuten Antwort.
Dann wird er wieder was gefragt, dann antwortet er wieder sieben Minuten,
dann machst du eine zweite Stimme draus und dann nochmal eine dritte und das
wechselst du dann untereinander ab.
Du bist ein bisschen lebendiger wenn du so machst. Und zwei,
drei Sätze synthesisiert auf einmal und dann musst du es halt mit Audio-Technik,
schneiden und irgendwie damit irgendwas mit der Stimme passiert.
Du hast also normal Olaf, excited Olaf, angry Olaf.
Stefans Olaf, Philips Olaf, wir haben hier ein paar Olafs drin.
Wir haben hier den Olaf Social, kann ich den mal abspielen?
Ja, mach.
Ja? Okay, dann kommt der Social Olaf.
Das klingt auf jeden Fall sehr nach ihm. Also das merkt man sofort.
Aber das war trotzdem harte Arbeit. Dann hast du irgendwann,
okay, dann bist du bei einem Punkt, du hast eine Audiospur,
weil du es irgendwann geschafft hast, dich durch diese Dinger durchzufriemeln,
so viel synthetisiert, das verworfen, wieder gemacht und dann brauchst du das Video als nächstes.
Und da gibt es dann so Techniken, es gibt zwei verschiedene Techniken und wir
haben uns leider, muss ich sagen, auf die falsche meiner Meinung nach konzentriert,
denn es gibt einerseits die Face Swapping Technik,
das heißt, ich mache irgendwas und setze ein anderes neues Gesicht drauf, sozusagen.
Der Nachteil ist, Face Swapping, nicht Swap wie der Corona Swap, Swapping.
Und da wiederum das Tool DeepFaceLab ist da so, dass im Open Source Bereich,
glaube ich, so das State of the Art, auch drei Jahre alt oder so,
aber gibt nichts Neueres.
Und da machst du so, dass du quasi, da bräuchte, also für unseren Fall hätten
wir dann ein Studio gebraucht und hätte man alles organisieren können,
wir waren damit aber zu spät.
Studio gebraucht und da hätte man jemanden, der auch nur 1,70m groß ist ungefähr,
also jemanden, der so ein bisschen so ein Olaf Scholz ist von der Statur,
in einem Olaf Scholz Anzug vor so eine Deutschlandfahne hinstellen müssen und
sagen müssen und dann noch Haare abschneiden.
Denn Haare können Face-Geschichten gar nicht, Haare ganz schlecht.
Und dann hätte der diese Rede so halten können und wir hätten danach einfach
das Gesicht von Olaf Scholz drauf gemacht und dann unsere Audiospur eingespielt.
Also quasi der Schauspieler hätte nach unserer Audiospur reden müssen.
Dann hätten wir das Video, das Rohvideo in guter Qualität und dann hätten wir
einfach ein Face gehabt und dann DeepFaceLab, das rechnet dann so nach Modellen,
das Gesicht raus und du hast so Gesichtsmasken und dann brauchst du Iterations,
das dauert alles unglaublich lang, du hast unglaublich viel GPU-Power,
die da drauf muss, du brauchst, glaube ich, 150, 250.000 Iterations,
das dauert alles ewig, bis du ein halbwegs gutes Ergebnis hast.
Und vor allem hast du dein Ergebnis, wenn es dir nicht gefällt,
kannst du von vorn anfangen. Und wir haben auf die Lip-Syncing-Technik gesetzt.
Das heißt, du spielst ein Video von dem ein und es laufen irgendwelche Python-Anwendungen,
die quasi sagen, ich rechne dem den Mund, ich rechne den Mund auf die Sprache
zurecht und das ist was, was einfach auch alles drei Jahre alt oder zwei oder
Und das sind alles irgendwelche Research-Paper auf GitHub, die sagen,
du guckst dir das an und dann sagen die, ey, ich hab das geilste Tool.
Weil guck mal, hier ist mein Video, wo ich das vergleiche. Da hast du Wave2Lib,
dann hast du Wave2LibHD, dann hast du OpenFace und so.
Und die vergleichen, die machen die nebeneinander und du denkst,
okay, euer ist das am geilsten.
Aber dann brauchst du ein Jahr, um das zu installieren, weil das alles so mega
schlecht dokumentiert ist. Dann machst du das und am Ende ist es doch scheiße,
weil das alles auf so diesen einen Satz, der da sagt.
Mit dem bist du dann in Stärkung. Und vor allem, die sind alle auf chinesische
Models. Das kommt alles aus China.
Und wir haben mit dieser Technik echt gefightet. Du sagst jetzt ein neuer Schnipsel.
Ich setze also dieser Teil vom Video, mache ich mit diesem Audio.
Dann ändere ich irgendwelche Thresholds, dass es halbwegs besser wird.
Dann lasse ich es wieder durchrechnen, dann dauert es aber erst mal wieder 10
Minuten. dann hast du ein Ergebnis, das ist entweder besser oder schlechter.
Wenn es scheiße ist, nimmst du einen anderen Schnipsel aus dem Video und machst
es wieder drauf und so weiter, bis du irgendwann zum Ergebnis kommst.
Und am schlimmsten ist es, wenn die die Fresse, wenn er die Fresse halten soll.
Schaut euch nochmal unser Video an und guckt.
Wir haben dann damit gearbeitet, wir haben so und so viel Scholz, der funktioniert.
Und immer wenn er abkackt, von den Lippen her, gehen wir einfach auf Footage.
Also dann machen wir einen Schnitt und gehen auf irgendwelches anderes Material von Scholz weg.
Und das Schlimmste, ihr werdet nie sehen, wie er auch nur eine Sekunde in dem
Video den Mund ... Wenn ihr einen Deepfake erkennen wollt, guckt euch einen
Moment an, wo der Sprecher nichts sagt.
Denn das sieht mit diesen Tools, zumindest die es gibt, sieht das so aus,
als hätte er gerade so den von Lord Voldemort persönlichen Schweigefluch auf.
Wie beim Matrix so, der Mund zusammen ist, ne?
Der Mund wird so zusammen, dahinter ist so Kau wie nach 20 LSD drin.
Also es sieht fürchterlich aus.
Also Facebook hätte euch natürlich auch noch die Möglichkeit gegeben komplett
andere Setting zu machen.
Das stimmt, genau. Und es gibt vor allem jetzt, es gibt jetzt Hightech,
also deswegen, wenn man sich jetzt diese Frage stellt, oh der Deepfake ist da,
das Zentrum hat es bewiesen. Würde ich sagen nein.
Also so natürlich Regierungen würden das oder besser produzieren,
aber es ist auch nicht so, dass jeder Depp mit sowas kommt, weil das ist super
anstrengend und aufwendig und vor allem mega time consuming.
Aber was es jetzt gibt und woher das übrigens kommt, die Technik,
die kommt übrigens auch nicht aus Russland oder China, die Marktführer.
Die Marktführer von dieser Technik sitzen alle in den USA und heißen,
es gibt Metaphysics und Flawless.
Bei beiden wollten wir, haben wir angefragt, aber haben noch nicht mal eine
Rückmeldung. Heute kam eine Rückmeldung von Metaphysics bekommen und da geht es um etwas anderes.
Da geht es um das Geschäftsmodell zu sagen, ich habe hier den Brad Pitt und
der Brad Pitt, dem mache ich jetzt so einen AI-Klon.
Und dann kann der, wir beide, oder wir und, wir können die dann lizenzieren
an Filmstudios und quasi so Stunts geiler machen und sowas geiler machen.
Und dafür wird aber ein Scan von deinem, da wird richtig, da wird nicht irgendwelches
Videomaterial genommen und gesagt, ich manipuliere das hier,
sondern da wirst du vor irgendwelchen Scans, Laserscans, dein Gesicht scannen.
Das trainiert wochenlang.
Hier geht es der Filmindustrie um zwei Sachen. Einerseits darum,
hier die Actors können ihre Personen lizenzieren und zweitens Dubbing.
Synchronsprecher und so weiter. All das wird es in fünf Jahren wahrscheinlich nicht mehr geben.
Also, dass man sagt, um ein Video, und deswegen, diese Tontechnik ist weit, das hat man ja gehört,
aber dass man sagt, was kommen wird, ist, dass man sagt, die produzieren einen
Film in Hollywood und dann wird die Stimme des englischen Schauspielers quasi auf Deutsch ausgegeben,
und die Lippenbewegungen werden so angepasst, dass quasi die gesamte Dubbingindustrie
ausgebotet wird aus diesem Programm.
Und da sind Millionen und Milliarden drin und das liegt aber alles in den USA
und dort in Hollywood, weil die dafür ein Business-Modell haben.
Ich glaube nicht, dass in Russland irgendwo unter der Erde eine Trollfabrik ist.
Die benutzen genau die Technik, die wir jetzt benutzen, nämlich GitHub-Kram,
den sie sich zusammenpacken, ein anderes Gun-Modell und nochmal ein Threshold
hoch und runter und ewig Zeit haben.
Aber die bahnbrechenden quasi Also die Neuerungen in dem Sektor,
die kommen mit Venture Capital aus den USA.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja auch für die ein riesen Ding.
Also auch so das Problem, wenn Schauspieler am Set sterben und dann der Film
nicht zu Ende gedreht werden kann und das hatten wir ja alle schon gehabt so
und Star Wars braucht jetzt auch nochmal sozusagen alte Schauspieler.
Ja, gut, aber… Aber das erklärt eigentlich auch, wenn du dir darüber Gedanken
machst, also die Diskussion über Deepfakes, die ist ja schon ein bisschen älter.
Ich erinnere mich, dass das seit einiger Zeit ein bisschen größeres Thema ist, ja.
Irgendwann im April glaub ich dieses Jahres war ich da zu dem Thema,
irgendwie bei Markus Lanz, da war das ein bisschen größer,
aber was einem ja auch mal auffallen sollte ist, hat ja nie einer einen gesehen,
was man sieht sind beeindruckende Bilder von Mid Journey oder so,
Aber wirklich jetzt Videos, da kenne ich nur dieses eine Tom Cruise Beispiel,
das ist glaube ich von diesen Flawless AI, die du gerade erwähnt hast.
Genau Tom Cruise von Flawless. Die haben jeweils so einen Trailer,
kann man sich jeweils angucken, was die können.
Aber das ist ja auch das ultimative, was sie können, was sie in dem Trailer zeigen.
Genau, das ist das ultimative, was sie können, das ist quasi das beste,
was die hingekriegt haben mit sehr viel Geld, wenige Minuten,
um irgendwie anzugeben.
Und um neue Finanzierungsrunden für Startups reinzuholen.
Und Finanzierungsrunden zu spielen und zu sagen, wenn wir uns alle Mühe geben,
ist das die Qualität, die wir zu liefern in der Lage sind.
Was Deepfake eigentlich als Problem ist, 99%,
aller Deepfakes kommen von Rechten. Im Moment schon.
Der eine, der gut war, kam halt jetzt von uns, sag ich jetzt mal so.
Aber 99% kommt von rechten und das sind alles Bilder.
Viel schlimmer in dem Deepfake-Kontext ist, weil Video ist zu schlecht,
das ist wirklich noch klar erkennbar,
natürlich muss man sich da drüber Gedanken machen, aber Video von,
das meiste kommt auf rechten Kanälen als Bilder von hier wird Frau,
weiße Frau wird von 10 Migranten aus dem,
Und das ist da, das ist omnipräsent, also checkt Twitter und so weiter,
das ist da überall schon, dass da Fake-Bilder am Start sind,
mit denen Stimmung gemacht wird.
Und genau dagegen tut die Bundesregierung meiner Sachen nach im Moment eigentlich nix.
Also es gibt weder eine Gesetzesänderung, ich weiß gar nicht,
wie man's regulieren oder bestrafen kann.
Ja hier dieser eine, hier mit so aggressiven Ausländern, nein zu noch mehr Flüchtlingen,
Norbert Kleinwächter, stellvertretender AfD-Fraktionsvorsitzender,
der solche Sachen dann teilt und auch wirklich, ja also...
Und das sind Fake News und die laufen die ganze Zeit überall.
Ich würde, also wenn das jetzt ein echtes Bild wäre, würde es übrigens diese
Hetze nicht besser machen.
Da würde ich gerne trennen, also er hat hier, ich glaube dieses Bild was er
da jetzt hat, da sind jetzt irgendwie Männer mit schwarzen Haaren und stärkerem Bartwuchs zu sehen,
die irgendwie aggressiv gucken, noch ein bisschen KI verformte Gesichter und
dann eben diese Überschrift oder Unterschrift nein zu noch mehr Flüchtlingen,
so ein Foto würdest du auch irgendwo finden und könntest das aus dem Kontext
reißen, ne? Also ich finde.
Ich erinnere mich genau, dass ich Anfang des Jahres, guck mal hier,
das ist ja genau 31.3., das war genau so um April rum, ich erinnere,
mich, dass ich damals auch dazu gesagt habe, man muss auch aufpassen,
das Schlimme daran ist Hetze,
dass der die jetzt mit KI macht oder vermutlich mit Journey macht,
ist eigentlich das kleinere Problem dabei, weil er täuscht ja jetzt auch nicht eine Unwahrheit vor.
Er sagt einfach nur nein zu noch mehr Flüchtlingen. Schlimmer ist das hier,
regelmäßig neue Einzelfälle, Afghane attackiert Mädchen mit Reizgas.
Da ist wahrscheinlich die Behauptung unwahr und das...
Das Mädchen halt noch mit KI generiert. Aber das wahre Vergehen oder das wahre
Schlimme liegt ja in der Hetze generell.
Aber ist auch eh schlimm, du nimmst ja da Sachen, da war das Beispiel der Einzelfallticker,
was ein fürchterliches Ding ist, denn da werden explizit unter aller Arten von
Kriminalität und sonst was die passiert wird quasi, Die werden Sachen,
die ein rassistisches Ressentiment bedienen, rausgepickt und ungeprüft mit Hinblick
auf irgendwelche Medienberichte oder sonst was gepostet.
Aber da gibt es auch kein Recht auf eine Gegend, das wird einfach nur so reingepackt
wie wir haben Recht, die Ausländer machen alles.
Auch übrigens der Einzelfeldticker ist wirklich was, was in meiner Meinung nach
gegen quasi unsere Verfassung eigentlich verstößt komplett.
Ich erinnere mich, dass es das gab, also es gibt es immer noch, meine Güte.
Jaja, das kam gerade da raus. Aber die meisten Deepfakes passieren die ganze
Zeit und kommen von rechts und kommen aus Mid Journey und Stable Diffusion Kram
raus und sind eigentlich Bilder. Bilder.
Nicht Videos. Und das ist im Moment der Stand.
Also nehmen wir, halten wir es kurz zusammenfassend fest.
Stimmgenerierung gut, idealerweise aber kurze Sätzchen, eine Rede da mitzumachen,
ist auch schon eine ganze Menge Arbeit.
Auf jeden Fall. Das ist tagelange Arbeit.
Und dann habt ihr ein Video genommen, ein existierendes Video und da drin rumgeschnipst
und im Prinzip auch Satz für Satz dann mit dem Wave to Lip?
Ne, am Ende war es, also wir haben mit Wave to Lip und allen Versionen,
wer das auf GitHub checkt, da gibt es 1000 Forks, die alle sagen,
wir sind noch einen Millimeter besser.
Wir haben das alles ausprobiert und am Ende war es eine Mischung sogar,
also daraus und das sogenannte D-Net und Open Face.
Was aber auch im Prinzip die ähnliche Libraries hat.
Da ist so das Open Face Mundmasken herausrechnet und in eine CSV-Datei exportiert.
Und du dann das in D-Net reinlädst und damit das Gesicht wieder sehen willst,
dann kannst du noch ein bisschen drin rum machen.
Aber letztlich ist das vom Tech Stack her wirklich alles sehr ähnlich und das
gleiche eigentlich, also in verschiedener Abwandlung, sagen wir mal so.
Und es ist wirklich bei Weitem nicht da. Wer das mal auf einfache Art und Weise
ausprobieren kann, man kann sich bei Think Diffusion, da kann man sich so einen,
glaube ich, sogar kostenlosen Start Package, da kriegst du so eine Art Stable Diffusion Cloud.
Und Think Diffusion, da kann man sich, glaube ich, kostenlos ein Startding holen
und kriegt eine Stunde umsonst, das reicht, um ein paar Sekunden Video zu generieren.
Und die haben nämlich Wave2Lib als quasi ganz einfache Online-Geschichte am
Start. Nicht, dass jetzt hier 1000 Deepfakes entstehen.
Morgen haben wir Olaf, morgen lebt auf einmal Helmut Kohl wieder.
Und wie viele Stunden, jetzt da gibt es natürlich noch die ganze restliche Arbeit,
nur den Scholz da hinzubasteln, wie viele Personentage würdest du sagen?
Ewig, also warte mal, ich würde sagen mindestens mal, ich habe selber,
weil ich am Ende so frustriert war, es gab jemanden, der war technisch damit
beauftragt und dann kam da wieder was, Dann hab ich gedacht,
oh, jetzt wieder dieser Schweigefluch auf dem Mund und so.
Dann hab ich selber mir Nächte um die Ohren geschlagen am Wochenende und geguckt, geht noch nicht das.
Dann hab ich sogar mal irgendwo gefragt, kann mir jemand, weil ich so ein Tool
nicht zum Laufen gebracht hab, dann hat mir das jemand, der bestimmt auch den
Podcast hört, dann mal zum Laufen gebracht.
Dann Ergebnis wieder Scheiße und so. Keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich oberhalb von 50 Personentagen. nur für diese wenigen Sekunden,
die man in Scholz bei uns sieht.
So fies. Und dann gab es natürlich noch einen Cutter, der das alles dann verschnitten hat.
Tontechnik, klar. Wie halt so eine Videoproduktion läuft. Aber ewig.
Also 50 Tage.
Genau, also allein die 14, oder vielleicht waren es auch nur 40,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall massiv viel.
Und auch ganze Tage, wo du einfach am Abend ein Ergebnis kriegst und sagst,
das ist eigentlich schlechter als was wir gestern hatten.
Aber hat sich gelohnt und hat den entsprechenden Etat, den Millionen Etat,
den ihr gebraucht hättet, eigentlich, glaube ich, Nennenswert reduziert.
Insofern super.
Apropos Millionen Etat, es gibt natürlich auf unserer Webseite,
kann man immer noch spenden, da gibt es dann tolle Geschenke von der Bundesregierung.
AfD-Quartett, AfD-Skat, es gibt eine Höcke-Puppe.
Es gibt eine Hörkerpuppe, eine Anti-Stress-Puppe, es,
gibt,
AfD-Verbot-Klebeband,
das,
könnt,
ihr,
dann, wenn ihr unbedingt müsst, könnt ihr es auf andere AfD-Werbung theoretisch,
draufkleben, ist ein Klebeband, wie ein Gaffa-Tape, aber mit AfD-Verbot-Logo. Gibt Feuerzeuge,
ja
wie,
gesagt, Die Puppe und so weiter. Und hier bei Logbuch und Netzpolitik gibt es
das geile T-Shirt mit dem Überwachungs-Elch.
Der Dartnelch.
Der überwacht dich.
Ja, ich schaue mir gerade die Perks an.
Der Dartnelch ist dazu da, damit du auch noch am entferntesten,
entlegensten Ort in Brandenburg deine Fake-Videos hochladen kannst.
Genau, dass du überall an deine Hetze kommst. An deine tägliche Funktion.
Ja, achja, das ist ein Drama.
Okay, jetzt hast du also einen relativ, relativ hohen Aufwand gehabt,
relativ teilweise frustrierende Erfahrung, aber auch ein großartiges Ergebnis für eure Seite.
Da gibt es jetzt einen gewissen Disconnect zu der öffentlichen Debatte.
Die Deepfakes sind überall, ja haben wir auch gesagt, in Videoform nicht,
aber in Fotoform tatsächlich sehr viel. Auch in der Israel-Palästina-Auseinandersetzung,
spielt,
das ja eine Rolle, dass da Leute irgendwelche Bilder machen, die nicht echt sind.
Wie betrachtest du denn die Perspektive, fünf Jahre, drei Jahre,
ein Jahr bis wir wirklich in dieser Welt leben, vor der sich gerade alle fürchten,
dass Deepfakes auf einmal überall sind und wir der Wahrheit nicht mehr trauen können?
Ich könnte das nicht auf eine Jahreszahl quantifizieren und du musst ja auch
immer sehen, dass da die Technik wächst auch auf der Gegenseite mit,
also es wird auch bessere Möglichkeiten geben, das zu identifizieren.
Jetzt gerade ist es so, dass es was viel gefährlicheres gibt,
nämlich das bestimmte Teil der Bevölkerung, also das eine ist ja,
wir spielen sowas in die generelle Bevölkerung aus und gucken, wie die reagiert.
Es gibt aber jetzt gerade auf Twitter, wenn so ein Deepfake kommt oder wenn
irgendjemand in dieser rechten Bubble irgendwas sagt, dann wird das egal,
wie schlecht der Fake ist oder auch wenn gar kein Bild dabei ist.
Hier hat der das und das passiert.
Das wird geglaubt. Es gibt ein Disconnect.
Keiner glaubt den öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien mehr irgendwas.
Leute sind faktenresistent und das ist eine Sache, die läuft seit Jahren und
die ist viel gefährlicher.
Die Leute brauchen noch nicht mal mehr ein Video, um gefickt zu werden und wenn
du denen ein Video so fakest und sagst, guck mal, das ist die Gegenteilung,
die glauben dir sowieso egal, was sie sehen, schon gar nicht,
egal ob es jetzt fake ist oder echt oder nicht oder sonst was,
weil die nur noch das glauben, was sie in ihrer Bubble da wollen.
Und ich glaube, dass das Einzige, was man wirklich tun kann,
ist, also so, es wird dieser Moment kommen, aber der Videobeweis zählt eh schon nicht.
Hier, guck mal, Video, da sagen die eh schon, das ist ja eh gefakest oder so, in bestimmten Bubbles.
Da gibt es die Mehrheitsbevölkerung und da muss man sagen, genauso wie wir damals
aufgewachsen sind, dann kamen die Computer und dann war sowas und dann musste
man andere Sachen neu lernen, so ist das halt jetzt auch.
Wenn man sagt, wie die Regierung das gerade macht, wenn man sich das so einfach
macht und sagt, da muss halt Deepfake dran stehen, dann ist halt ein Deepfake,
aber wenn nicht Deepfake dran steht, ist halt kein Deepfake.
Da kann man sich jetzt schon ausrechnen, wie krass das in die Hose geht.
Letzte Sendung hat Tim, das fand ich mega lustig, gesagt, wir müssen uns immer
so Sachen überlegen und nachdenken und so weiter, aber wenn du Politiker bist,
dann blaberst du einfach irgendeine Scheiße und das machen wir am Magnetschwebeband.
Ja und wenn du dir das so einfach machst wie das Bundespräsidium,
dann muss auch die Bundesregierung stehen, da kommt ein Watermark oder so, keine Ahnung,
das ist dem Problem so tonnenweise zu tief gegriffen, da musst du sagen, wir machen,
es gibt bis heute kein, mein Sohn, ich habe Kinder und die gehen auch zur Schule
und ich denke so, er weiß überhaupt keine Sachkunde in Computerfragen und so.
Du verzweifelst da, die sitzen vor wirklich ohne Scheiß so Computern,
die brauchen 5 Minuten um anzugehen.
Dann sind die an, dann hast du alles veraltet. Wenn man es mal ernst meinen würde.
Die brauchen auch 5 Minuten zum Ausgehen.
Das Gute ist, da kannst du kein Fake News Video drauf angucken.
Aber zuhause haben die halt alle TikTok, sonst was, Ding, dann läuft das so
durch. Überhaupt keine Medienkompetenz.
Daher kommt das. Es geht hier im Kern.
Egal wie gut der Deepfake ist, du wirst ihn nicht mit so einem Schild entlarven, Vorsicht Deepfake.
Sondern der Weg dahin ist wirklich
Medienkompetenz von früh auf und durch alle Schichten und Klassen.
Einfach zu sagen, ey, es gibt ja auch sogar so Bildungsurlaubsgeschichten,
die machen aber auch wieder nur die Akademiker.
Du hast doch jetzt schon Recht auf Bildungsurlaub. Man könnte auch sagen,
es gibt recht auf Sonderschulung, Medienkompetenz, 4 Tage im Jahr.
Wenn du Bock hast weiter zu buckeln, geh halt weiter buckeln.
Aber du kriegst genauso deinen Lohn, wenn du jetzt so Medienkompetenz,
Schulung, da und da. Da muss natürlich auch diese Infrastruktur geben.
Aber wer sagt, YouTube, mach mal runter, Zensur, weg.
Und wenn der Bundesregierung, sonst muss da halt Fake stehen.
Der ist auf dem besten Wege, das jetzt auch wieder so richtig zu verkacken. Das ist meine Meinung.
Das schöne ist, ich erinnere mich daran, genau das ist auch meine Meinung zu
diesem Thema, diese Technologie fällt auf fruchtbaren Boden.
Und dieser fruchtbare Boden, solange der da ist, wirst du es technologisch nicht lösen können.
Natürlich, du kannst es technologisch überhaupt gar nicht lösen.
In fünf Jahren, also jetzt schon, kann dir Hollywood sowas liefern in perfekter
Qualität. Und wir können es in so halbgarer Qualität.
Und diese Technologie, da werden gerade Milliarden rein investiert.
Obwohl man sagt, Fake News ist böse, dann kriegen wir gesagt,
oh, das böse Zentrum macht Deepfake-Videos.
Aber gleichzeitig werden Milliarden in diese Technik investiert,
um sich dann den Synchronstudios zu entledigen. Und es ist bei jeder Technologie
so, dass du so einen Top-Down-Effekt hast.
Also es kommt quasi, die Hollywood-Studios oder ganz weit oben wird es entwickelt
und dann wird es nach unten lizenziert, um so breitere Märkte anzusprechen in
bestimmten Qualitätsstufen und irgendwann kommt es halt als App.
Dann habe ich so eine App und dann wird das vielleicht gesperrt,
die App, aber diese Technik wird kommen und man hat auch nicht mehr ewig Zeit.
Und die Zeit reicht aber, um die Bevölkerung darauf vorzubereiten und so,
man muss es halt nur auch tun.
Aber dann ist das das Problem.
Ja, es wird halt einfach überhaupt gar nichts getan.
So ist das.
Ich würde gerne noch ein Gauland hören.
Ah, ein Gauland. Oh, den muss ich erst mal produzieren. Ich hab den natürlich
wieder nicht produziert.
Während des Livestreams kann man sagen, hier, wir wollen jetzt hier noch ein Gauland haben.
Hat der halt nicht seine Badehose jemals wiedergefunden? Oder seine Badeklamotten?
Das hat der nämlich, der Gauland hat in seiner, die Badeklamotten waren weg. Ja klar, die waren da.
Der Gauland, ich habe eine Sendung von Maischberger, ich gucke eigentlich das
nicht, aber dann wurde ich darauf hingewiesen und habe es mir doch angeguckt.
Und der Gauland war so geil, letzte Woche war der bei Maischberger und zum Thema
AfD-Verbot, da war der FDP ehemalige Außenminister, wie heißt der denn?
Der ehemalige Innenminister von der FDP, ganz alter Kreis mittlerweile.
Achso, Gerd Baum.
Und die waren so im Battle, die waren im Battle gegeneinander, Gauland gegen Baum.
Das ist so ungefähr, da gibt's so diesen Spruch, was kümmert es denn Baum,
wenn sich die Eiche angibt, die Sau an ihm schwirrt.
Die deutsche Eiche.
Und die Maischbäcker, ungewohnt schlagfertig tatsächlich und hat so den echt
genagelt, den Gauland mit so Zitaten, weil dann ist so der Höcke,
wir befinden uns im Status des Vorbürgerkrieges jetzt hier und so.
Also was haben sie dazu gesagt?
Ja, ich hätte andere Worte gewählt,
aber und dann kommt immer so eine Relativierung und dann hat die ihm wirklich
eins nach dem anderen gesagt und was ist mit dem Zitat und was ist mit dem Zitat
und der hier will und Gauden hat es echt geschafft so in der Sendung gefühlt sieben oder zehn mal,
ja, also ich hätte andere Worte, das hätte ich nicht so gesagt,
aber, aber, aber und dann immer gefunden, wie es dann doch, wie er es dann doch
so schafft zu relativieren.
Und hat der Baum dann auch noch drauf gehauen?
Der hat auch drauf gehauen. Also ist tatsächlich Stuff, den man sich angucken
kann, also Baum, weil Baum hat… Baum ist Ederk.
Jaja, also das war tatsächlich eine der besseren Stunden des öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehens.
Ja, die soll es ja auch geben. Gibt es da eine Aufzeichnung im Netz bestimmt, ne? Finden wir den Link.
Ja, und dann hast du irgendwie den Gauland da aus der Sendung rausgesamplet oder…?
Nee, hab ich nicht rausgesamplet. Ähm, ähm.
Aber du hast ja auch Gauland produziert.
Nee, Gauland produziert haben wir aus anderen Sachen. Die hatten wir schon vorher.
Aber ihr musstet auch alle erst mal produzieren. Die gibt's jetzt noch nicht
als fertige Stimme im Netz.
Nee, nee.
Ja also so hätte ich es nicht gesagt halt.
Ja nee klar.
Ja gut, das war die Sendung Maischberger und der Gauland. Wie geht es hier weiter?
Ich denke wir leiten das Ende ein oder?
Ja, wir können das dann auch mal zum Abschluss bringen, weil das war ja mal wieder spannend.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin nach wie vor ein großer Fan von eurer Arbeit,
weil sie nicht nur politisch engagiert ist,
sondern auch so eine Finesse und vor allem auch einen guten Satz an Humor immer
mit sich bringt und das schätze ich doch sehr.
Das findet auf jeden Fall meine Anerkennung, ich bin ein bisschen begeistert auch.
Es ist auch nicht nur anstrengend. Es ist mega anstrengend, so Sachen zu produzieren,
gerade in der Zeit davor.
Da muss ich auch sagen, ich setze mich hin und erzähle davon,
aber eigentlich muss man sich an allen Stellen bedanken, die mitgewirkt haben,
weil das sind extrem viele.
Und man muss aber auch sagen, es ist nicht nur anstrengend, es ist auch mitunter echt witzig.
Dann wird unser YouTube-Ding runtergeladen und wir sehen das Ding und du denkst dir nur so, geil,
was, hä, wie? Und das heißt, das macht durchaus auch Spaß.
Die Arbeit machen unsere Fördermitglieder, wir nennen sie Komplizen möglich,
wer vielleicht überlegt, Um mal eine Komplizenswerft abzuschließen,
ist sofort steuerwirksam und kann über unsere Website gemacht werden.
Weil ihr gemeinnützig seid?
Noch.
Weil ihr noch gemeinnützig seid.
Weil wir noch gemeinnützig sind, genau. Aber wer jetzt hört und sagt,
ich mach das nur wegen Steuersparen, der braucht nicht kommen.
Also wir würden uns schon freuen, wenn unsere Fördermitglieder auch nach der
Gemeinnützigkeit noch dabei sind. oder nach einer Machtergreifung oder was auch immer.
Denn eins kann ich sagen, also da spreche ich auf jeden Fall für alle,
das ist schon so ein bisschen, man ist so ein Überzeugungstäter mit der Sache.
Also das macht keiner, weil er sagt, ich habe hier einen Job drin oder sonst
irgendwas, sondern wenn du so arbeiten willst, dann musst du eigentlich von
der Sache überzeugt sein.
Und das ist wirklich von oben nach unten in jeder Ebene zu spüren.
Und deswegen ist es auch ein wahnsinnig so mutmachender Moment,
wenn wir, wir haben jetzt zwei Jahre auch wegen, weil wir extremen rechtlichen
Terror wegen Flyerservice Hahn hatten,
haben uns echt zurückgehalten und sind nicht so in die Vollen gegangen.
Jetzt ist das langsam, das ist langsam so Land in Sicht.
Die Sachen sind eigentlich vielfach entschieden und dann macht man endlich mal
wieder was nach zwei Jahren.
Wir haben wirklich nur ein ganz Mini-Ding gemacht und dann merkt man,
okay, das ist auch so, das ist sinnstiftend, in so einer Gruppe zu arbeiten.
Aber ihr seid schon die Ersten, die an die Wand gestellt werden.
Ich bin weg dann. Ich bin weg. Ich hau dann sofort ab.
Ich guck die entsprechende Wahl schon aus dem Ausland.
Wollen wir mal nicht hoffen, dass du bald kommst.
Also hey, unter unserer Website könnt ihr meine Flucht finanzieren.
Ey Stefan, endlich hatten wir dich mal in der Sendung.
Ja mega geil, hat super mega Spaß gemacht.
Es ist auch eine große Freude, dir zuzuhören. Es war mir klar,
dass das, also die Sendung hat meine Erwartungen erfüllt.
Ich hoffe auch die der Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ich finde das nämlich toll,
auch mal wirklich so ein bisschen länger über die Aktionen zu reden.
Und ja kann dir nur alles Gute wünschen.
Da haben wir auch selten übrigens die Gelegenheit so geil zu,
wie ich es jetzt hier hatte.
Ja, das hab ich mir fast gedacht. Ich muss es ja sonst immer am Telefon anhören.
Nein, geile Sache. Alles Gute für das gesamte Zentrum und alle,
die da mit beigetragen haben, mit Infrastruktur aufgebaut haben,
kleine Sachen, große Sachen.
Und natürlich auch das Kernteam um Philipp und wer da jetzt alles auch vielleicht
gar nicht genannt werden möchte.
Die Anwälte, man.
Danke an die Anwälte.
Ihr macht das möglich. Wir sagen immer, die Anwälte sind die wahren Künstler.
Danke an, schönen Gruß an SKW, schönen Gruß an JWW. Mit dem Lied möchte ich meine Anwälte grüßen.
Hiermit geschehen. Alright, dann war's das.
Du wolltest doch dein komisches Soundbatter jetzt.
Soll ich?
Dachte ich.
Mach ich doch glatt.
Wie viel Zeit haben wir? Aber da können wir gar nicht drüber reden.
Da dreht doch dein Ophonic eh wieder durch. Das kriegen wir seit drei Jahren
mit den Terminen nicht hin.
Das werden wir mal sehen. Das ist schon besser geworden, glaube ich.
Aber das wird kaputt gehen dabei.
Wir sagen jetzt tschüss. Bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.